welcome to my tutorial on set solving so
this is part of a boot camp of uh
berkeley institute seminar on the theory
in practical aspects of sat solving and
originally this was planned as a kind of
life physical event and berkeley
institute in california but then through
these due to this corona and kobe thing
we had to move everything online and
therefore i decided to to do this a
little bit differently than it was
originally planned to to happen so
originally there was like a plan for one
day tutorials on on particular important
um
subjects like to get people going
but
it's not possible and so we're doing
videos now and uh so i thought like um
these videos um
you can find them on the internet
actually you find lots of them um even
from me on talking about um sad solving
just one recent one at the saturn smt
indian winter school so i recommend that
one and there are slides and
so i try to do this a little bit
differently so today we're going to do
something which i call um
blackboard
okay that's uh what we have here that's
a blackboard um but i'm also doing uh c
and c
means uh uh code and um
you're you'll see um
that um in a in a minute so what we're
going to do is to to actually um while
we'll talking about like um
uh the basics and the algorithms i'm
going to show you how this really works
in practice
and therefore um i recommend um that
while you try to um
follow this video maybe to stop it now
uh go to the web and download
this repository
this is a sad silver i hacked
particularly from scratch for this
event here the reason
being um i have done something similar
for tutorial give in 2012
back then it was called cleanling and i
just wanted to to redo this
thing
properly now with with the
new insights and simplified
uh also in certain ways
all right i hope you had a chance to
download it um then let's see um
what have we have here first of all uh
satch rhymes on scratch so there's a c
in an r missing when it's actually in c
so if you
see these files and maybe i'll i'll
explain maybe first things uh to find
your way around and then we'll talk
about everything so uh first of all
there's a readme which
explains things um um so it's like a set
so written from scratch and it's meant
to be
um simple code base so it's very very
simpler than my other service keysight
and catechol
and which have been really successful in
the last two competitions
um and and you want to use them for
production maybe
but this is much more instructive and
much smaller um so so you see here for
instance um
the that it really um only consists of
um this uh
code here um
and um
um like one file in which everything of
the solver is uh that's uh um
here um
in this one uh then there is uh
like a stack the only container actually
needed and a configuration very small
one for um
[Music]
for
uh light pass i keep keeping the build
information around uh and and then
at the end here uh this line which says
uh okay um it's an application code you
need a parser actually put i think prod
robust parser in the witness printer and
then there's the build system in version
you find the version and maybe we'll
look at this for a second so the version
i'm talking about here in this video is
version 0.2.4
and
then
we have make files and uh yeah i'll talk
about these things um maybe later a
little bit and um
so you can compile the whole thing as we
just saw by just issuing configured so
this will
generate a make file we can say make and
then the server is built
and then we can also do
run
some cnfs solves them and then at the
end also tries a little bit of api
testing even though this is not complete
for this solver
yet
okay so you should try this
and maybe um
also try maybe like one of these test
cases because this will
print some nice output
so
this is the output so the reading
then yeah it starts solving
i'm so going to explain these things
later and and then at the end there's
the result it's unsatisfiable this s
here is from the sub computation uh
output format in case you haven't seen
that so like this is sort of the most
important line in this file
if you for instance put
here um just write um q for minus q then
when you only get this file uh
this line with unsatisfiable then some
profiling information and then some
statistics and and the end memory and
time usage and then the silver exits and
this exit code here is really the exit
code so if we
ask the shell what was the xe code it
was 20 that's also like a common format
from the site competition where we had
like
10 for
satisfied formula and 24 for
unsatisfiable formulas
and of course the same would work for
status
distance which factors these numbers and
therefore it's uh because it's a square
of two prime numbers it's uh
uh satisfiable and if i do that then uh
you get here exit code one uh but more
important you get here these numbers
like um first of all again and like a
solution line but now um it says
satisfiable instead of unsatisfiable and
then the solution here is printed as
so-called witnesses line or v lines
value lines uh where is it if you write
the
the variable um positively or negatively
you might wonder why do these variables
not have name well that's the dye mix
format and maybe that's the next thing i
i show uh for a second uh so if you look
at this instance you see here um this is
a typical side instance uh with uh
this is like a prefix and um that's
called that it's a cnf
and then here you have the number of
variables occurring in these files and
this is the number of clauses so if you
go down here you see like
it's like
this many lines and bytes and uh
right and
furthermore these are the actual clauses
um and cnf's are like that but before i
explain more about it you just need to
think of this as um well uh it would be
as
if you would have maybe i picked this
one with the mixed
so this would be the same as writing
sort of not x 25
or
[Music]
x 24 right then you have a symbolic
representation and then comes the next
clause and this clause would be x 8 or
not
x 24
or um x 25 and so on and these are all
connected
with ends and so on all right
so this is kind of
and
this is kind of our task how do you
build a tool which which
solves
such
instances
so let's talk about the input format of
a set solver so um
it's a conjunctive normal form and you
must have seen this before so let me
just like make an example so we have two
variables uh m and s and of obviously in
these uh kovi times will have a shirt
like my t-shirt i'm wearing here we and
we also have a
mask
and
of course we'll just talk about now like
conditions on these uh on these
variables so let's assume then if i have
a shirt and then i have to wear a mask
if i wear a mask i should wear a shirt
that would be really strange right
and then like one of the two should be
true so this would be um
like three constraints and because
they're in cnf we're putting end
together now these um
um
these
implications here they're a little bit
strange so um let's just um
transform them into a real uh cnf and
and that would be um
there was an end uh
that was would be like replacing the
the um
implication by by
this junction
and then we'll get these three clauses
right um
and that's like our cnf now in this form
it's already like less readable than
here
in the middle and uh but it's um i guess
it's pretty natural to think in in terms
of such constraints for certain things
but let's not stop here so let's just
now uh simply say that like the shirt
here is um
we have a number one um so once again
right so we discussed this before we
interpret this is x one and this is x
two and and then um
we um have the dimex format simply as um
a rate like not shared which means uh
minus one um or uh two rate and zero for
terminating the clause and then the
opposite so two implies one
and the end
one of them is true
okay you see that of course like i'm
used to to reading this uh dynamics
format um
which is literally very fast but it's
also pretty simple so you have two
variables
and three clauses
and and you could give
this to a sad sober
okay now the question is is this thing
um as satisfiable
and um
well
um
it is why
because
if you think about it you're um
then one of these clauses here
so sorry these these
three clauses are all the clauses which
which um
exists uh with two variables
except for um
one clause right so the clause which is
not here is is
uh not s or or not m right
and um so that would say i i should not
neither were ma i should
not wear a mask
and a shirt at the same time right it's
negation of um not s
and m
and
um these
four clauses would be unsatisfiable why
because um you have four
assignments so these two variables and
each of them would be blocked by one of
these clauses and so blocking all of
them would just make the formula
unsatisfied but because
it's satisfiable uh we're going to have
a satisfying assignment which is exactly
the opposite of the clause which is
missing
um which is s and m so you can think of
um
s is true and uh m is true satisfies uh
these uh uh three clauses why well you
also see that um
yeah this is uh true here right and um
and and this year is false
um you can also think of the other way
so i'm making all variables true and
each clause contains one one true
available so that's why it's satisfiable
okay so this concludes my my
introduction into to cnf
all right now let's see whether we can
also do this example um with the sad
solar so for that we'll just start a new
um file which we call as in
cnf and then put in this like our two
variables in three clauses remember the
first implication was one implies two
second one two implies one in the third
one one of them is true now we can
so when when we get like um yeah it's
satisfiable remember that this code here
but we'll also get this satisfying
assignment namely that's the shirt here
is uh true and also
the mask is true okay so this is how
satisfiable instances work now if i
would do the same with an unsatisfied
instances remember the sun it was became
answers but if i had this clause i need
to make it four clauses now and then the
whole thing becomes unsatisfiable um
as
expected
all right what we're now going to do is
i'm trying to get an a bigger problem
into
to cnf and then we're going to do what
people call
the setting
encoding or
transformation right
and um
for this example i use my favorite
uh sort of like um
well there's some more but this is one
of my favorites so we're going to use a
distributivity law from bulging algebra
which looks like
this right so you get an a or b and then
your uh
can
replace replace this by um
a a or c
all right and um uh
so um let's uh keep this uh example um
now what we're going to do is to
introduce variables for this individual
uh nodes here like i mean operators and
and this is better
seen
in in circuit format and um it has the
additional advantage that uh the the
circuit um
the circuit um you can apply the satin
transformation to the circuit
as well
um so um
let's look at this left one we have an a
here and then we have a b and the c and
the the b and the c are uh go into an
and gate
which then goes into an or gate which
has a as first one and then
this conjunction is second one and this
is our output
okay and then
we want to know that this is the same
and i'll talk about this in a second
as the one on the right and um
for that we're going to use um
an x or this isn't uh
an end or a xor
and
i'll i'll say more about this in a
minute and and the output we're going to
denote by o
okay and then you of course you see that
the top one here
is an and gate right and this n gate
has
two two or gates uh as input and uh
[Music]
all right and
uh they they have the the common um
[Music]
uh b uh the common a here as uh
as
this is used in both but then the the
right one has a c
in the left one
um
a b
module like commutativity of this
these gates right and
and in principle um
right uh what you really want to do is
kind of uh get here uh uh this b and
also here instead of this a you want to
get this b but
um i'll just assume that they really the
same uh inputs here for for readability
and now the question is how do we get um
this into um to a cnf and um basically
what we're going to do is we're going to
put new variables and mark them
with blue for each of these gates so if
we have like for instance um have here
um
here uh an x variable for this or gate
here y variable for this y guild here uh
z
for uh this and gate and maybe here u
and uh and v for these guys okay
and then we simply write down like what
these compute and then let's do this
here so um
let's start from the left so from the
left we have u
is equal
to a
and v okay
and um
and then we do it for the the
the other gates and so
um
we have
a wii is equal to
b and c so this is an input gate
and um and so on so z is equal to to x
and y and x is equal to p or a
and finally um
y is equal to a and
sorry
or c okay
um right now this is a obviously a
linear algorithm right but it's still
not a cnf so how do we get now from this
to the cnf
well we need to translate each of these
individual clauses here into c and f
and and and for that let's uh maybe um
look at um
this clause here right um
so we're having um
u is equal to a and v
and and you can think of this constraint
as u implies a
and
u
implies um
b and then both of them a and
we imply
you right
okay now um maybe at the end so we're
going to turn this line to a real c in f
but i guess you can see this already so
it's new new um
a
um and and because i'm licking space i'm
using a strange notation here right
but i get i guess you get the the idea
the bars such as the disjunctions and uh
um sorry i didn't do this
and uh
right so this is a cnf
so when encoding um such circuits
there's
one thing to consider it's
in
in constraints is sometimes called arc
consistency and um i would call it maybe
um
redundancy
and um
for an example uh consider sort of um
you have here a gate it's like an
equation like that in the neat example
with the
with the satan uh problem where we now
have a condition and
if the condition is true then we'll get
um an
a a true case uh so the then part
otherwise we get the else part
so think of this as this question mark
calling operators in in commonly you
know used in
in in programming languages you can also
think of this as uh if conditioned and
then
it's else or um
uh or people would also sometimes maybe
um
call this
con something like for conditional or
okay i get i think i get the point in
the point now and the way
how how you can encode this into satan
would be if c is true then then x is
equal to t
and if c is false then
x is equal to l straight
and where the equal sign is now um this
is
um
i'm loading sort of highest priority now
and then you you encode this further so
um
um this is the same as if if if c
implies then
then x implies
t
and
um
t implies x okay and and and here it's
the opposite this is if c is true then x
implies e
and e implies x
and
uh yeah and then we flatten it as we did
before um so um
because this is an ore um and then this
this thing here becomes uh
an ore
and we're going to to to erase here
the um
um
location and put the negation here and
then we can use our distributivity law
and also remove this implications
and then at the end get like
six clauses which i'm now dropping the
the or again like i did in this one
example
and
i get that one
and i get c and t bar and x and
i get
c and x bar and e
and
c
e bar and x okay
okay so this looks looks looks pretty
good just to send a check um so like for
70 chicken look at this one so if the
condition is true and the then part is
true then the output of this
thing here should also be true this is
also sometimes called um in circuits a
multiplexer so where you can have here
c as a selector and um
then t
or else is input and then depending on c
you get
one of these two guys rate
max for multiplexer
um
[Music]
so um yeah um
we now need to um discuss the following
things so if you uh think about um
[Music]
this um
this last one here um
then as about this uh operator then it's
clear that if
uh t
is equal uh to e right
then uh uh of course x is equal let's
say to t
um so
and um if you think about it this is a
redundant um
resentent constraint
um and
it for instance would give us here
the
um
the the
formula if both e and t
are are true right so both true
then uh uh also accessed to be true and
if both of them are false right that's
right
false right then
x just to perform so we would have this
uh
additional um
redundant uh
clauses
however
as it turns out they can be resolved by
by resolving on the um
on the um
on the condition here so if we take uh
this first class here this one here
we'll take it here and
and and move it
here and and you take this third claws
here
also move it here and then we'll do um
resolution
uh between these two on on on the um
uh variable here not c
well then uh we're getting exactly um
uh what we wanted so we get not x
um
t or e right this is our uh is the
second one here
um
okay and this is also true for the other
one so so the message is that if you're
these um
uh these uh
pink classes down here uh they are um
it would give you sort of more power to
the encoding right because if you think
about it like the set server knows that
e and t are true then it will
immediately
deduce from these that axis has to be
true
however they can be resolved from
already existing classes from from these
original classes which we we're having
here uh uh and those would be um what we
would call um
irredundent
and therefore in a set server would um
want to only have these um irrelevant
clauses uh to simply to keep the formula
simple but it might internally actually
derive these redundant causes and and
therefore um depending on like how
powerful the satsa is you you want to
explicitly encode this redundancy but
most of the time you
you do not want to do it um you can also
think of it in the following way so if
you think about like you give all six to
the sad silver and the sets of it needs
to ha has a procedure which determines
that uh well terrain clauses which are
the result of resolving two timer
clauses would be redundant then the sat
silver would remove those and would
spend like effort which you could have
avoided um
anyhow from the very beginning
so what i've shown you so far on the bit
level um these are constraints which you
would want to use to encode execution of
a program but often
a problem encoding in the site also has
certain
constraints
and
these constraints are more of a logical
nature and therefore um
maybe different methods are needed i'm
giving you two examples here the first
one are cardinality constraints and but
of course like not really the the
ultimate explanation for this and the
other one will be something about fixed
points so what are cardinality
constraints well we saw already before
in example so the
kind of
majority gate is one for over three bits
but like the the um carryout we had
before
was uh was actually you can think of is
um if you take the input
a bits right and you sum them up so this
plus here uh this is really sort of um
natural numbers uh okay
natural numbers plus
where you kind of interpret really true
and false is his concentrate
and then we're asking whether this is a
larger equal than two this was the
majority gate thing
okay so in principle this these are
called cardinality constraints so
they're kind of
linear programs where the variables are
0 1 and the coefficient here is always 1
of course
and
these are
actually all
exactly the their conjunction and or
like um
is exactly the set of um
boolean
of symmetric functions but that's not
the point now actually something which
goes back to shen and i want to show you
like assume you have um
this
constraint here abcd
and and um you want it to be
larger than two and
smaller than three oops three
and that so that means there are
at least
two of these four are are true and that
most three so how do you encode that of
course now you could sort of um
take an approach and think about like
ruling out all the impossible ways uh of
assigning this variable but another one
a circuit like approach and that's what
i'm going to show you here is based on
on baby days uh and and so so what we do
is we have here um
a bdd note this you need to to think of
um and
a note here reads um this down here with
a stroke here this is the then part and
then we'll have a dashed version at the
right and that's the
else part uh in in there it's the uh
variable okay and then if a a is true
right then we're going to sorry if a is
false and we're going to check b
if b is false we're going to check c
and then if this is is is false
uh we're well then we know that all four
are false and this is clearly a false
rate and then we'll get to um a second
row and we do the um like diagonally the
same uh variables so um
and bddds um our obdd's
are
have this requirement and the variables
are always kind of here tested in the
same order
and
so uh
we're going to do exactly the same again
so we're going with an else to the right
and
um
and here we know that at this point
we have also zero because
there's exactly one variable true right
you went down sort of like
one way here uh and one of these four
ways and that's like in most one
variables you will not satisfy yet
okay now we're um we're done actually
with the a's and b so now we're doing um
a c check here now two are true
okay
and
we still need to do here uh uh a d check
um
and
now we now go to the right
we now know that um exactly two uh
variable suction rules this is what we
wanted so we can put a
one here right and yeah right you see
like for instance if you went this way
you you had like a two variable source
you went this way you have um two
variables right
um all right now um
and the same here is true here for for
the d um down here where um
well um
[Music]
um
if if i went down here then then my my
three variables here uh which i had in
this vertical line are true and also
like if you go this way and i didn't
draw this yet uh
so um
this would also be true
however if you make d also true then
your false right so it doesn't fit
anymore
okay now you're doing uh we need to
introduce like it's 18 variables is
before right
rst and um
and so on right and then we're going to
encode like each of them um
as a constraint so for instance we would
here uh have that
b um
uh sorry a y here this y here we can
almost cannot read it so it's a badly
written by let me
try to draw it again
so this y here
is
such a mux which we considered before if
b is true then we get s downward right
and otherwise the
the t all right and then we'll continue
and get our like uh four classes right
so that means um
we're going to have here like with this
four three two
plus one um like um
seven plus three
um ten um
such maxes and uh of course some of them
simplify so it's really don't really
need like 40 clauses but that's the idea
you also see that
if you if you're um kind of put here um
an um an arbitrary constant here to the
right uh so uh let's say we're putting
here um a
k um
and this would be n variables
then this this whole thing here is in
the order of uh uh o n k
which could be uh quadratic and there
are other ways in the in the literature
which make this
cheaper uh but
in many cases this bdd based
version i'm showing you is still a
pretty useful
and
at least sort of it's a very natural way
of
doing constraints
so the next thing i want to show you is
related to
other types of constraints which are
really um often and i would call them
maybe fixed points uh constraints
and the typical example would be
uh temple logic
and the encoding of temporal logic um
instead of for instance the
um
the visibility of um
of
um
the existence of a path
uh if you aware of that that's kind of a
um
at least fixed point
but there are many other examples like
reachability in the graph so think about
instead of um having encoding a sudoku
and you want to know that something is
reachable and you also get to this uh
least fixed point but more abstractly um
let's uh let's assume you have
an equation which looks like that
okay
kind of bad why sorry about that
and and then the y is like a b or x okay
then this set of equations of course
there's a solution like for instance you
make a
solution for x and y no matter what a
and p are
these like just put x and y to true
so the largest fixed point uh largest
solution here is
for x and y is x and y equal to one okay
but if maybe your semantic of this
mutually exclusive
uh
equation is
that you want to really have the sort of
implication of why it's the smallest
formula
then um
of course the the solution
is um
x of um y is the same as a or b
uh and that's not that easy to encode i
mean like you could
take this and and generate like um
um like what would be six clauses and uh
but that's not like uh um what the um
that's not the correct way of uh
encoding this um only uh for the largest
fixed point for the smallest six point
you're making a mistake here and um
there's a kind of a whole field if you
want uh
the one which called asp or answer set
programming which
talks about so-called stable models
where you kind of need to make sure that
you kind of
not cyclically um
assume something so this solution here
would be a cyclic solution so i got this
wrong
yeah sorry no i got it right and that if
you want to avoid the cyclic solutions
you might either sort of like
dynamically or just to build directly
into the
sad silver um uh detect these cycles and
and avoid them for that of course you
would need to know that for example why
you want like these solutions
so before we now look at um side
algorithms we're going to um look at
one more
um kind of encoding part and then
i let it be so the
the the question is how do you get like
more complex like a c program of the
execution c program now into um like uh
cnf i mean we now know how to get the
circuit the bit level circuit into safe
next step is like how can you get
something more more complicated
and
for this um let's let's assume we want
to compute um
[Music]
the beat vector addition of two bit
vectors
of length four so you can um um
um sorry i should not have written like
four so it's better to think of this as
uh like uh three bit vectors which have
uh um as two as one um as
zero as bits like four bits and we we
add um this kind of um
the same with the
bits together x uh one x zero um
plus um
plus
y a3
y2 y1
y 0 okay
um
how do we do that and the basic idea is
that you just need to compile a hardware
circuit for it and then take the satan
encoding of the software circuit
and then for those who of you who went
through digital uh um design courses
that's pretty simple but let me just
like explicitly explain uh how this
stands so what we're actually doing is
we're um
using uh full letters and full letters
here are uh like boxes it looks like
that they have three inputs x and y and
usually
carry in and they um produce um
some output and um
like s and also like um
you can think of this as a carry out so
i call it o
um
and
then i will take these full letters and
and put them together um in the
following way so we're having now first
of all just write down the semantics so
s is then the the same
as the x or
between the three input bits okay oops
and uh
um
x um xor
between the
and in all three odd that s is odd if uh
all three even then s is uh true
and so if all three are even then s is
false and then we also have this uh
carry out here which is majority gate
people call it because it takes sort of
the value
of the maturity of its inputs um but
it's also symmetric so
um but you can also think of it as a
cardinality constraint
which
and simply checks whether um two of them
are true
and that's by this big disjunction like
that now you take um what we're now
going to do is just
um taking uh these full adders and
plugging in here the uh the uh the bits
so here we're putting actually
a constant zero and then we get um s is
zero um then we get the the next full
adder and we're getting s1 so maybe i'll
just not uh maybe draw these arrows but
the others are are kind of clear so we
could x1
y1
and um
yeah this is kind of the input of of
that one so it should go here uh to the
left maybe
i should have
written here this
differently and put here the
the the eye here as an arrow here uh
from the left okay
and then we'll put here um
um a zero in
and and this here is of course um just
a y zero
okay and then we continue doing the like
this uh two more times and
then get all the
desired output bit
and that that carry here can be
ignored
okay and since all these guys are not
just circuits you just have to
have to um like use now that satan
encoding in this way you can get like uh
four beat edition
um
[Music]
and um yeah you can do the same then of
course with other operators like we
would call these guys um kind of um
world level um operators um
um
or if you want uh um
if you're an smt person you would call
it big letters
so what i've shown you here is kind of
how do you get to bit vectors or word
level expressions into gate levels which
is a classical hardware design problem
and then we have this gate level like
this circuits then we can go to
two formulas the beauty about this is
that um you can really do this kind of
um for all kinds of real executions of
machines where you don't really abstract
something to something continuous
and that's why this is a
is a very useful
technique
all right so next we're going to talk
about um actual everything so so i would
call this um
the
uh p
versus um dpll uh and i won't talk much
about this first thing here so this is
for davis putnam because
this would be pre-processing and i don't
have time uh in this video to talk about
pre-processing so what we're going to to
look at is this dpl and i assume that
most of you have seen this so i tried to
be a pretty fast here so so um again
like in the dimex notation i'm going to
use now
uh like one two three four x two x three
right i guess you get the point right so
this is kind of uh x
or
x3 right and then uh we put here uh lots
of ends around it let me just forget
about this and keep the
um just one two three uh then we're
going to have
the negation of this
second one and then start over again
with the same i think you're you know
where this is heading so we're going to
um
really have here all the possible
clauses uh with
three variables straight so this should
be 16.
and um
now
we're
going to
play um are trying to solve this formula
first of all this formula unsatisfiable
yes of course it is unsatisfiable for
the same reason we discussed before um
for the
simple example with the mask and the
street
um classes here a rule each class rules
are exactly one assignment of uh three
variables since they're like eight like
eight such assignments and each will
clause rules out uh exactly one for
instance this last one rules out this
assignment will all are true this first
one here so rules are to the assignment
they are all false
this um rules are all possible
that is now let's do this with the set
server and the um the the classical way
of doing this is a dpl search tree so
you're kind of uh look um it's like a
bdd right so you would for instance a
peak here a variable let's say we're
picking a one as valuable ring
and then
we make it true for instance so we use
the same symbols as in in the
in the um
sorry as for the bds in the coding for
the canali constraint
then um here here's you see that uh
this uh this first uh clauses here uh
are all true right but uh here uh these
four are false but nothing happens
because
there's still like in all clauses like
two literals left so it's possible so it
would in principle possible to satisfy
them
okay nothing happens here but the next
step would be we're going to um
assign here um
variable um
two to true okay
all right
and now we're getting the situation that
these clauses are gone but it's really
kind of strange to actually even
consider them
but we're going to have now um
this clause
and this clause where two literals are
false okay
um so if for some reason right so our um
sad silver works by walking downwards
this list to find such a case it would
find this clause here first
and then call this um a unit clause
um and and we'll uh force this guy here
uh to true
so so
um
we're uh actually um kind of uh taking
uh this clause here and
and use it here
to to assign um
uh three to true and and these guys were
a decision but this guy not so this guy
has only one um
um
one outgoing edge as we'll see in a
thing so this is not a decision so um
but um now
we figure out that
uh this
class down here um
here
is conflict
thing
so we often say conflicting so this
literature is not clear about that but
it's called the conflicting or
conflict clause i like that from
conflicting more
but let's uh not go into that so why
well because
now um
[Music]
this not three here is uh also uh also
false right and while um yeah these
clauses
and the red ones here would be also at
the tools here okay i think i get you
get the point okay
um
okay now this over um backtracks and so
backtrack here by just pressing ctrl
uh set uh so um
and
now um well again in this situation
where two is true then we said we're
going to imply three but this is
uh okay so so now we're getting the
first time
uh to um two equal to um false rate so
now uh um
these guys here are false
uh and the other causes are true and
then you would see again maybe with this
argument that we get here downward and
then and like see this clause here first
we're force
this to a unit
okay so so we have the same situation as
before so we
setting three to true but not with the
second branch and then get of course in
exactly the same
conflict um
as we had before conflict
okay
and of course this would continue um
then with backtracking and then we'll
maybe do two again we could also do
three by the way but doesn't matter
right and we'll get um
also by unit propagation again
to two conflicts
and that would be
then would then show that the the
formula
is
unsatisfiable
okay now um
let's um move on to the core algorithm
of um
of the um
of satsang which is cbcl
so let's go go back to the start of the
the tree so it looks almost the same
also the
the the example here
um
so if we we're signing uh two to true
right then we're getting um
again uh our um
our conflict down here right
okay
um so maybe again
signing three uh first to true okay and
then get the conflict by our
clause down here
but now we would say okay um let's see
what was the reason for
for this conflict we made some um
assumptions
and the the assumptions are these two
guys okay
so what we really said was if one is
true
and
two is true
okay
then
false so i now need to use bottom
because otherwise
uh it's conflicting with the zero
something all right so i guess you get
the point um all right so that means uh
what i really know is
that one and two is a clause cannot be
true
all further this is the same as saying
that clause
-2
is not
possible
uh with these uh two with this formula
so so once again is if if if this is our
formula
and and this is our new clause what we
kind of showed by
um f
and c
and and we nowadays to call this unit
propagation
if this gives button okay
then
we know that
sorry not c look at the wrong thing
we call it alpha which
is the negation of c okay i'll come back
to this in a second to bottom then
we're getting um f um
f uh implies uh um c
okay alpha
is supposed to be not c
um and therefore um f is actually the
same
as f
and c
and that's what i kind of did here so i
added here
my c
okay so so revert this
until the point where we derived the c
um
so
we now know that the c can be added to
the formula okay and if you look
carefully um
at this c
uh then you will see that
it's a little bit strange because
well
if you look at this graph here then at
this position here
um we we made the decision three
okay
but that's not good because um
um
[Music]
all right so
decision three we made a decision two
two to be true but that's not good
because um
if you look at this class if you if you
would have this clause here then then
this is false right
and therefore
this has to be a unit class right
and for not two so that means um
i should not have done this
i should have
immediately just after one
take the
unit
implication here this two
as a unit as you did it before with this
with the three okay but like now with
only one outgoing edge because uh it's
false okay
so this year is not a decision right so
this is an implied unit
and and furthermore one thing which
might be important here is um this
clause here
this clause here
here um
is a learned clause we call it and it's
responsible here for
for um
for implication of of the two
so so what's this cdcl doing here um
[Music]
this conflict driven
clause clause clause learning here
well it's uh it works like a dpl but
then um in a situation like this one it
tries to figure out what are the
reasons for for my failure getting into
this dead end like my um
conflict down here
and then i i learn um the reasons which
is
something i can add to the formula
and then i figure out okay so if i have
this in the formula
uh
and and i kind of backtrack and
reconsider the the way how i get here
then i will figure out okay
and that's guaranteed
well i would not have taken one of the
decisions i've done before right so you
you collect all the decisions which led
to this bad situation and then you have
to undo one of them
and therefore this
situation this
decision here
becomes a propagation
of the negation of it right so so you
can see that here it's a 1 and here it's
a false
2 to
true and the right one is 2 to one
a two two zero
and um this is in principle the the idea
between conflict driven clause learning
i mean where we could continue now that
so if you do uh here the um if we
continue and um
you will see that as before um
that's um
uh now of course like these colors don't
match anymore so i'm not going to uh to
to do this any further but you will see
that then after one more decision
um then you will get um a conflict and
um
[Music]
sorry not not even after one decision
what's going to happen here is uh this
uh two to false rate which i just erased
here uh will lead to um like another
conflict actually it will be here a
conflict with this uh here in this
particular uh uh two uh clauses so so
this one is now false this first one and
then three and not three are are in
conflict
and uh then
i will um again try to collect the
reasons for that and the only reason we
have having here is this
one so what we're going to do actually
next is to learn
here the negation of of the single
decision which is then the clause not
one the single clause not one so once
again
we we have that f
and
one
uh per unit propagation like looking at
these units uh will get into um bottom
and therefore we know that um
f um
is the same so actually the f prime
after in this binary clause
is the same as
f prime and adding the binary clause not
one
all right
so
and actually this happens quite
frequently learning these units and in
the
we're going to look at this
in the code or the output of the set
server next
all right now let's see about
how this works in practice so i have
here in the um the such uh
directory of russian suite
which
uses these formulas so this regression
suite here is called by by this guy like
a shell script and
yeah we're going to look now at
this file here which is a larger one um
and
it has produces is expected to produce a
20 as output as unsatisfiable so let's
let's let's have a look at this
formula so if i run it then we're
getting
uh answered of course as expected
and i have pretty fast so in 4000
conflicts
maybe i should also explain some more
statistics here so this is the number of
decisions taken
um so you see there's like way more
decisions than conflicts like that well
because first of all um the the solver
needs to is restarting what we're going
to discuss
at one point too and then um
uh well um you're going to sort of go
down and you're making wrong decisions
then the cdcl has a way of um covering
up for these decisions and then it jumps
over decisions which which were
redundant and and that also means that
you have usually
more decisions than conflicts the next
um
statistic you want to look at here is um
propagations this is the number of
assignments in essence and also sort of
the the number of times you found them
um
you you you walk this list of clauses to
figure out whether there's a unit or
a conflict and that's again another
order of magnitude larger and this is
very typical usually it's actually even
more so like two orders of magnitude
and um
so maybe this already gives you a flavor
how this is done so you're going like
like really deep you propagate a lot
like for every decision you propagate
maybe you assign to 10 more units right
remember we had this
one these notes in the in the tree
in cdcl which you have only one
successor these are all propagations and
usually for one set of real decisions
you have 10 of these
implied propagations
um and also like this is really the
hotspot of the the silver we'll talk
about this uh
later a little bit more
what i want to show you also here is
this output here um so first uh maybe i
need to explain how you read that so
there's like um here kind of a header
which is like for this small example
barely readable but um i try to explain
it of course like we had like 2280
valuables and then this many original
clauses and then initially 100 of the
variables are still there and and then
this sort of does something and then it
hits the first conflict so this is you
barely see it it's really sort of below
this conflict header there
and and that's the point i wanted to
make this conflict actually leads to
learning a unit clause so that's when
this i is printed so this i
means iteration i don't know why i
called it like that but in my solvers it
means
you learn the unit clause and it happens
quite frequently right you see like one
two three four
five six seven unit clauses um eight
nine
and then um you're getting close to um
uh you find the empty course and this is
the code that your the formula is
unsatisfiable
um
[Music]
and this already happens for the first
conflict so the soul really went down
the branch and um
the very first conflict detected was one
where after analyzing the reasons why uh
this conflict happens
you realize there's only one decision
necessary to get that and that's then
the the conflicting um
the learned clause it's negation
actually all right now next uh uh
happens here after six conflicts
after uh five more right we again learn
a unit rate
so um
and also the number four year but is now
um going down so for this first unit we
only were able to sort of like remove
make one variable in active which is
this unit learn but here we are actually
jumping from you see
2279 to 77 so we're going down by seven
and the reason for that is well because
we're we learned this unit and then we
propagated and only after propagating we
actually print this line and then um
there yeah this learned unit implied
another unit
uh like on the top level another
variable
and that's why um even though we just
learned uh two unions here we removed a
kind of three variables which will
become a site
okay um then
next thing i want to show you here is
this line here this is the
reduction so this number here also goes
up you can see it also barely here
and this minus so minus for removing
clauses that needs to be done quite
often actually in the silver so here we
do it after
300 clauses and what what's the purpose
of this well it removes clauses which
are
redundant
so not all conflicts
lead to
clauses you learn so so here you see we
have 300
conflicts but we have only 272
clauses here some of them are actually
um
not necessary and learn and
so that means like from this
to 298 because the two unit clauses are
of course not not added
um
some of them were removed um and that
continues here so um now from this 588
conflicts only 469
redundant clauses remain
and you see this this is going on so
this is number of conflicts and this is
the um
the the number of redundant clauses
okay
right and um
um
of course
maybe another way to think about this is
is that sort of you're
you're trying to sort of like learn
child and show the clauses um because
this kind of
removes some part of the search and then
um at one point of course like when you
continue learning short and show the
classes you will learn a unit and these
are these eyes and it really happens um
quite uh frequently
now back to the plate board so one
important um
um
data structure if you want and then it's
also a
rhythmic aspect of the cd cell
is what i would call the um
uh
implication graph and this goes back to
um show marcus silva and uh
and i'm going to this is really sort of
at the core of of cdcl and and extremely
useful to um to get like a fast
assets over so how does it work
okay so first of all we need to kind of
um maintain
um the um the
the
the assignment um off of the sad silver
and that's uh usually um done um
with some global um uh variable stack
and it's called actually a trail so like
this captures the uh
assignment
and and it grows like an upwards so it's
like um
[Music]
a stack and if you assign let's say a
variable one uh to true variable two to
false
and so on then uh you you crawl here
upward that's the trail okay and then
when you um
[Music]
make a decision you might push here four
on top of it uh you can backtrack and
then at minus four because it was
flipped um well and and so on
um
and then there's like usually
um in my servers are called values uh
another uh global table and and this
goes really sort of like from a smallest
variable um to um to the largest one and
and it actually is a ternary variable uh
ternary um
um um uh
contents right so like uh
these are on all variables right for all
variables you have this
and
um this just gives you which are
assigned so this is the two key data
structures you have
and with that you're already uh doing
pretty well then of course like we still
need to have the clauses uh like uh this
clause here for instance
and another clause
for minus six uh
one or so
and work with these and and these are
usually um also kept somehow in
something which is all again um again um
uh indexed by uh the whole uh variables
right
uh
and um
[Music]
um
and then it for each variable it would
have like two two entries like one for
the false occurrence and and in in the
other one for for the uh true
occurrences like the positive and the
negative the currency you can think of
this is sort of um actually um
here it's like maybe variable one minus
one two um
literal of course minus two
three minus three and and so on right
and then um
here y one right and would need to um to
have
a connection here and maybe it continues
here uh 2 would be
only here in this example this 3 would
go here
and so on right
and of course like what um one really
does in in in practice is to have here
um
actually
a stack
uh which
is usually a power of two so it could be
like a four for instance here
and and this would then um for instance
this one here would be keep a pointer
here uh to to
to these two
cases
so i think like this is
maybe um something one could figure out
um
already um
by yourself so usually i would call uh
this case for reasons which we're going
to
discuss later
watches but of course you can also think
of this as
occurrence lists like lists of
occurrences of a variable
all right but now
we also need to kind of um
remember how to um
to organize this
uh this learning and
um the way as i said is the implication
graph right and
this is now on top of what i just
showed right
my way of describing is is maybe um
slightly different than in the
literature and um
so
but i try to make it fit also like what
other people do so so here's like the
decision level um some people use here
um like an ad sign and the decision
level really starts at zero so here on
at zero there are all the units right
we discussed before when you learn a new
unit you will go to the top it doesn't
have any decision before it
um just like is something which you need
to do because it's forced
uh so let's assume we're having here
like in as in the example uh we have
here minus two is as a unit okay
and
also like what's in the literature would
be you right here the decision level at
zero
and then the the assignment so instead
of um
having here um the um
minus one to denote the literal which is
true uh in the literature you often see
uh such a note sorry not true
yeah because
i said like
the variable one is false so minus one
would be the literal uh we would see
this notation um i prefer now this one
because uh here um
[Music]
well the the level you see from sort of
the separation here so there's going to
be
another level here which is one
and
another
decision level two and another decision
level three
okay um
okay that might be multiple it could be
even that sort of like this unit because
there's a clause which say which has the
shape of one
or two
um that there's another literally
implied
on this level so this is not not from
the example let's just make this up okay
now um
here at the these these decision levels
we need to do make decisions let's
assume we're making here a decision with
the variable five
okay now it could be that um
we're going to um
[Music]
imply a literal seven directly
and this is then because of the clause
not five seven right
but we could also maybe do nine
but we need um
here um
[Music]
this
unit from the top and then you see this
nine here
actually has as reason the negation of
these two guys which is not five and
one is class right
so um
so this is the convention of this
implication graph you have their nodes
which are literals so sine variables and
um
they are predecessors like in this case
the predecessor here is five and
one right
they are the reasons the antecedents um
for for for the sky so um
maybe i i draw this in in a different
color um
so um
what i
mean here is uh this is kind of the the
reason gloss right
for uh for
for this thing here
and this was the reason clause for for
this thing here
okay this is how you read the um the the
but now let's continue building that um
so um maybe nothing happens here but
we're making for some reason um like a
decision
minus six then then minus six could uh
in principle here uh let's say with the
seven here
okay
and um
also
with the
with the nine
uh get to
let's say
what to do with f4 okay
um
but that
is in conflict and this is drawn like
like that with the copper
and actually maybe we can do this red
because it's a
copper
um for conflict um
[Music]
and we also plug in here now no
no no this guy
so if we now uh read off here the the
conflict then we'll get again the
negation of this guy which would be
not two not seven and not
nine and not four okay so there's a like
a class of length four which is now uh
falsified
uh uh okay so we're building this tree
like like we do here uh but what would
be the next step well we're going to um
to do a conflict analysis and the
conflict analysis here would be um as
follows so we're going to um
[Music]
consider here
this here as a first cut okay
this cut here through this graph
separates the the decisions
uh on this side right
from the cup of
um
and it corresponds to class and now in
this case the clause already
uh
exists actually um
in
in this
um that one by the way so i just forgot
there's like this is not possible so i
need to have another line let's pick
and
this line here
okay so we need to have here in addition
six
i can't see this
six is here
okay um
and what well why is that because um
actually what's an invariant here and
that's why i figured it out is this
these two edges are here these guys here
they're really necessary because um
there's an invariant in cd cell that
like when you get a conflict then and it
will only there will always be sort of
like two two literals contributing to
this uh conflict from the same decision
level from from this decision level two
and that's why i figured there's a
mistake uh and anyhow so like down we
need to of course like here have this
car to also go over this line
now the first step what one would do is
one would um
would try to find whether um there's
like another cut rate which uh which
would do um which would actually do the
same thing and um
all right so we're
cutting here now maybe maybe here
and um
and
that's um
because we're kind of
resolving here the um
the clause of uh of this assignment
so so this guy has as reason
not
nine
um
and not
seven both from decision level one
and
six okay
okay uh and if you resolve uh this class
it's really literally literally a
resolution so we take uh
this guy here and uh
this guy here
then we'll get uh from this the
the uh resolving which
takes out here the the six right
and
sorry not the six the four
this was a sixth this doesn't look good
here so just the second so this doesn't
look good so it's a six
and um
so the six remains of course and and in
the the result would be the six
then the not two
uh the
the nine is shared then the the not
seven is also shared and the field four
goes away because that's what um sorry
the four goes away and of course because
of the form has to have to be
in here right because it's the reason of
that
okay so if you resolve these two clauses
like the green one and the red one you
get this pink one uh this one and and
that would be then our learned clause
uh this
implication graphs also have another way
which i'm going to explain now in in in
with a different uh setup so less
complicated but um
um so we're going to uh to have now um
let's say we're not having any um
any unit that's like just irrelevant for
our example um but we're
we're going to have um here a decision
one here decision two
and this decision three
um now um let's let's let's say like one
it implies two and maybe not two uh
four and um minus five what about that
and then uh two does something else like
maybe minus six
maybe actually together here with this
uh four and and yeah just like uh for
you maybe start checking that you um
um you you have um the right answer now
let's assume we're we're going to um
um to um
to
to get um here to um
to the clause um
five
and
then we'll have
the conflict not 5
and we have the
conflict
with
these two guys
and maybe um
here uh these two guys so let me write
down the conflicting clause
so the conflicting glass has four uh
literals and let's start like on the top
here with minus five so it would be
five uh four
um and then um
three negated in seven
negated
okay and
now um
what you can
also see here is that
there's another cut which i now need to
draw
differently actually which looks like
this this will be the learned clause we
need to
resolve here um away our
i think i did this green before like we
need to solve away the the clause here
for um
the
the seven here which is just just three
right like the clause here would be uh
not three seven
with uh this class and then we'll get
the
the pink one
if you resolve these two guys
uh then you get
um seven goes away and we'll we'll get
uh five uh not for
not three
seven goes away five
yep
four five
and three
and four five three
okay
um
and uh that's a nice learning clause and
now what's going to happen is the
following that's the interesting part
none of these
clauses here in the um
in this decision level here
um at least a different color
so
none of these uh classes here in this
decision level uh literacy decision
level was actually needed right so you
really see that these two graphs last
two implements
are separated
and also if you look at this clause here
if you
think about the decision
levels here
so let me try if i can do this and so if
you do this blue
if you put the decision levels here you
would see that three was in decision
level three
uh right
this is set three
four was it one and this wasn't one so
this is the clause we're going to learn
but that clause now has a strange flavor
so so actually we'll call um these are
called um
[Music]
blocks
and you can think of this as a
as a decision level blocks
um
and the number of this like the the
number of these would be two
and that's called actually the lbd
glucose level like the number of
level or um the third term for it is
glue
so so this is um the number of levels
right the number of numbers here unique
numbers it's one and three here these
blue numbers of levels from the left
here
uh
uh projected on on the cross and there
this thing has only two levels but it
has size three
so this this already looks like um
interesting but more and this is sort of
the the really cool part here there is
no two right
uh so and that means if you think about
like when i explain cd0 what you should
do right like in cds
learns a clause and then tries to figure
out when did i make a mistake if i would
have known this clause already before
now this situation is clear right
because the decision too you would not
even have attempted because um
not naughty decision like three right
now both decisions that decision number
two and the decision level three are
would not have been taken because that
clause actually already at decision
level one here forces
uh three to be true right
um
so
so what what would happen here is into
this known orange is that actually will
will will learn here this clause and um
and
immediately um now in orange um derive
here
three right
we can do this on decision level
1 not decision level 2. so that means
we're completely
jumping over
over this level down here
and that's what
we call a back jumping right
to
level
one
well back tracking would of course be
this level but like the implication
graph allows you to figure that out
easily that like it just takes sort of
the the second highest block here the
second highest decision level which is
like this one
one and then you jump to that one and
then you force
the literal
okay there's the third part to that
which
i also want to explain
and um
and that's called a unique implication
a point right so um
so now i'm um
you
specialize in this topic to unique uh
implication
point
so what's that
well for those of you who have some
background and algorithms so this is
sometimes called articulation point uh
which decomposes a graph into um by
connected um disconnected components uh
but we're having here directly graph and
and so all we'll see how this goes
anyhow so uh uh now i started earlier so
i will put here um decision level um
later i mean this is a little one
because we don't have any units okay
and then we're we're doing here um an
implication uh two uh three and maybe
four
and then we have another decision level
which is uh
at two and and here we have a decision
um
running out of numbers uh four uh five
um implies uh uh nine
um and then we have down here um at this
issue a decision level three we have our
um
and and this together with the
with a nine here and all going to
because it's uh
important to see that that i'm going to
to to write down here the clause uh it's
like um
we're going to say not eleven not nine
and seven so i'm going to be forgot to
put
the seven here
um and then the seven has also a shape
like this one so we don't have a let's
say minus eight right and um and
and this gets us in
in in
uh
minus a together with this guy here
and and this gets us um into a conflict
with the decision with this guy
so this is our kappa then
which
um is false right
and
the um
yes not again so i didn't make a mistake
we have this nice uh property that like
the kappa has two incoming edges from
literals on the
low the highest decision level and the
clause would be not for
um eight because here with minus and uh
not seven
okay now um
now what kind of um cut do we get um
well uh we could have
gotten uh this card here okay
this is what we're going to call later
the decision
or
last eip clause
and
it's the one where the decision is in
india right this one this was oops sorry
this was 11.
um this clause here has the property
that it has
not 11
and then
not 9
not three and not four and if i'm going
to draw again the levels on top of it
for the blocks you see this is like the
first block is in level three and nine
is at level two and and three or four
are at level one right like three blocks
glucose level
um
three
uh right
and um
[Music]
and whether you backtrack well with this
one you would just backtrack to decision
level 2 right to
so the back track level
is of course
this is the back track level at the back
jump level
this one
yep and we would kind of continue here
all right now if
i do a slightly different cut um so the
cut goes here um stops here so at seven
so you don't resolve here further
uh i probably should take a different
color let's uh
maybe use uh orange again
uh so i i i start here um then
i still have to include the three
and also the four
so the eight is resolved away and then
i'll get this
but then my clause here
so this clause would be
um not seven and not three and not
four and if i again uh draw the decision
levels you will see with the same
situation as before
we only have two blocks and in
particular two is missing right
so that why our back jump level would be
now um
one
so that means we can actually back jump
here
so once again so this first clause uh
this is
the the
the last erp clause um this one was um
was was jumping back to decision level
two while this first uip clause here
first uap class
allows us uh to
backtrack to
a level one which is of course better
right
and also um so so i mean the there's
multiple arguments in this but the the
the introduction is of course you're
you're pruning more search you're
jumping over things which are redundant
um
a rule of thumb here is
uh that you shouldn't do um or you
should restrict the number of
resolutions you should do
so only going back as you few
solutions as possible but here's like
one thing
which is important this cut here has the
same property
um as this
is the first eip
while um this one is the
last uap
as this uh
first cut
so that means um if you if you really
look closer here this picture is that
it's uh it corresponds to a clause to a
little clause which only has exactly one
literal on the last decision level like
uh
seven for the first european 11 for the
last ump and that's exactly what um kind
of um
is important feature of these clauses uh
so once again uh here uh this level
three thing
uh is uh only happening once and this is
then the
the the kind of property of these
learned clauses and you stop immediately
then you after resolving when you find
the clause which has exactly this
property
um there is one more thing i want to
mention here you need to find those
urlps and how do you do that
and
the way to do this is actually you take
trail which we discussed before which
keeps the the partial assignments of the
stack as a topological order and then
you walk back this order and this way
you can always find this uh this kind of
articulation point without much uh
overhead
uh easily by counting how many sort of
variables are still here down on this
last decision level and as soon as this
number drops to one you found your
your clause and we're going to look at
that
uh in the code
next
all right so now we're going to look at
um some details of the code so my my
plan now is the following so i'm going
to to kind of dive down into this
function which does the the analysis
like which just
does the same thing what i just did on
the blackboard
uh but in real code but of course like
there are like a couple of things which
you need to understand first and these
are two things like how clauses are
represented and then how
how um
variables are
represented and and uh alternative would
have been i just go through sort of like
maybe literally the bottom up or but
then i thought like it's more useful if
you just sort of like take everything
which is needed to be able to understand
this part of the code and then we'll
later like
reiterate so it's kind of a cyclic way
of going through
the code
um okay so um
let's have um a look at
um
this code file so this is the main
library so um as i said like it's just
it's written in c and it's like
one single
[Music]
file with uh
some um
comments so i try to put only comments
which try to explain things i did not
put links to
references like in in catechol
but like the the thing i wanted to show
you here is first the representation of
the levels which is
explained here
you saw the dynamics format like where
we would have numbers
one and and two which are in the range
one and then of course here the maximum
number which can be
uh
sort of represented in into compliments
so so exactly two billions uh and you
can't imagine it's really like uh people
are sending me really big benchmarks and
uh um yeah so keysight my other server
has
like 256 million variable that's uh
barely enough but like lingaling which
is half under 28 million and like this
has been broken or this limit has been
hit a couple of times so anyhow so i
think like being on the safe side is
with 32 bit maybe in 10 years we're
going to have a hd6 for bit indices for
these variables so what you see here on
the left is of course the uh the dimex
format right so like variable one it's
negation two um
and
this would go here until it marks the
convenient
uh thing about this dynamics format is
that you have also this um sort of
sentinel which which is not used like
zero is a non-valid index uh you can
also not negate it right uh by the way
this is the same for the only number
missing here first two complements which
is int min but this is completely
illegal here so we just sort of our one
one number short here actually in the
dynamics format of uh what we could use
or you can think of it also uh this way
yeah well there's another variable or
value which i can sort of misuse for
strange things
this is pretty convenient for kind of
sort of
negation and thinking about this and
also the examples
however it turns out in in sad solvers
it's much more convenient to take
another
encoding and that you see here on the
right so once again this is the how
these variable indices are encoded while
in dynamics on the left they're just
like
these numbers and negation means not
now the right hand side you see like
this is kind of shifted by one
and in addition you're kind of um
uh multiplying the actual variable index
times two it's an unsigned integer so so
this goes up to slightly more than two
billion
and uh the sign is encoding the least
significant bit
and for that maybe i'll i'll show you
again um how how this is done
uh maybe in a blackboard so so you're um
you think of uh
if this is a variable index right
uh then um
these are kind of our um 30 to one
index bits
and the least significant bit here uh
this is the sign
i think i get you get the point um
and um
this this of course
then
uh gives us actually
yeah even maybe slightly one one more
variable but um okay one issue though
here is um that we need to change the
kind of invalid value here to something
else and then the uh code it's just like
uh
invalid it's called as a macro which is
this number here and and and actually
should be five here this is a typo here
uh um this this is a typo uh and it's a
an and you and unsigned into max
okay
so the reason why i'm showing you this
is because now if you go through the
code you need to think of terms like
these um variable indices they're not
like in dynamics like on the left no but
they're kind of re-encoded here in the
zero one two three where three is
negation of two
and so on
okay the next thing i i need to show you
is how yeah here's by the way this
invalid um definition
um is here um
the clause
[Music]
data and that's a little bit tricky so
forget this link down at the bottom this
is not interesting at the moment um so
here is this id we're currently using it
for two purposes uh for uh first of all
it's very useful for debugging because
you then you have uh
have have an id and then second
it's uh can be used as a tie breaker for
for sorting if you want uh
we need to sort clauses during loss
reduction
uh but it's sort of more um
a minor minor thing if you really want
it's probably possible to get rid of
this
8 bytes actually
because
well you just need to use a stable
sorting function and other things so
but for now we keep it to keep things
simple also easy to debug so next thing
are like flags i think the only one for
now interesting is this one um we're
separating the clauses into redundant
and irredundent clauses there's actually
a
stack in the silver i can show you this
later where you put the the redundant
and the
uh
irredundent clauses so uh maybe a little
bit confused that like three words and
actually the fourth word would be
original so what we really say is
they're like redundant and irredone and
no matter whether they sort of like how
you derive them so learn to have this
connotation that you learn them through
cdcl
uh and um
that's of course not really necessary to
know what the clause is
has been learned or it has been resolved
or some other method shrunken or
whatever
it's important to understand that
they're like clauses which are redundant
which you can always throw away because
the rest of the formula is satisfiably
equivalent or whether these
you have to keep it in order not to sort
of make a formula which is unsatisfiable
satisfiable and that's what this
bit is for of course like the learn
clauses built by default first become uh
redundant
then the next line here this glucose
level here uh this is already saw this
is the number of these blocks so these
were blue blocks in this uh
uh in the explanation for the
implication graph like the lbd or
glucose level i again use all three
uh words um
clues came up with this glucose level
the original order is called lbd i like
clue because it's the shortest
thing and you can pronounce it
then next comes uh the size of the uh
clause delaying the number of literals
and now comes something tricky which for
those of you who have not seen
c
might uh uh uh not have seen before so
this is a like uh
like a trick which really like uh i
would say gives you in the order of uh
almost factor two a speed and i'll
explain this in a second what this is so
let's go back to the blackboard
um
so we're having a clause right and the
clause has um
a size
uh so all right so we have the id and
then uh some flex
uh the um
the clue
and uh then um the size okay
and now uh in a class the classical kind
of uh object let's say maybe
object-oriented way so this is our
clause
you would now have here um
a reference to uh to the literals okay
and and they would be uh yeah literals
right so they are now unsigned right
three so this is three's in the
wall that doesn't make sense but but
four would make sense and then seven uh
that doesn't have to be sorted right so
this could be a nine uh and so on
and this is the size of the course and
um
uh however uh the problem is um these
clauses will then be sort of
sort of watched right and
if you now see this pictures you see
these three two big dots
and as i already said before the the
main um
uh work done in the satso is actually uh
propagation which means
walking here at these clauses
they usually actually sit as i explained
before
themselves in an array so you also have
a point of the reference here
but this is cheap this doesn't happen
that often
but this is really costly so so this is
costly this is dollar dollar dollar
all right this is probably dollar
uh
and and this is also expensive
because you kind of now have three
points of dereferences one two three
while while this is this is still the
most expensive one
but this is also
expensive and and you can completely get
rid of it if you're
a um if you're able to make the the the
the uh the area actually uh variation
rate and um
this is um uh works as follows so you
just have your size
but now you continue um just uh here
with the literals right
you put the literals here uh directly um
after it
i don't remember what we had we think we
had four and so on
okay then um you only pay one uh like
you've paid this dollar dollar uh point
of the reference is gone
so that's the reason
yep and the um
see actually um because it's such a
common
medium
allows this kind of variety um
declaration which says yeah here comes
an array but this area is embedded into
the object you're allocating and well
you need to carry yourself how big it is
and when you allocate it you also have
to be careful actually and see you
really have to precisely say how big the
the memory is you're using
and and that's uh that's um
important trick
in the code itself uh there's almost no
difference because the access to this
literals looks as if they would really
be like in the first version but of
course the compiler will realize that
this is different and that they are
embedded
um so you kind of you would call this
like embedded um variatic
literals allocation
all right so so this is i think what i
would need to show uh there are some
some more things which maybe i'll just
show in the assignment function here
um so uh this assign here this is like
what happens if you're uh remember like
we put something on the trail so that
means we're we're assigning this literal
here to true
and we will remember the reason for uh
assigning these literals um
okay you will see in a second how this
is done with the with the assignment
right so this clause is such a clause we
just have seen so this is a pointer to
such a closer reference
okay and uh there's some
overheads like extensive logging um
which serves as comments but also like
for debugging or for for seeing like
what's going on
then here there's a specific um um
check for um whether this thing isn't is
a root level uh uh
assignment if it's a root level
assignment then we record this right
this actually um uh is just a statistic
counter while this one here this active
was actually the second leg next to last
column we saw uh in this output like
when the number of variables goes down
because the variables are assigned
then here comes a trick which is um yep
everybody does it but it's painful for
many reasons and
i cannot completely explain it but the
trick is as follows as soon as you're
learning a unit like something which is
definitely implied by the formula and
it's a variable then you don't need the
reason anymore so it's like um you just
can't forget that clause because that
clause is now a root level satisfied by
that literal which you're assigning
and and therefore it's completely um
redundant and can be removed from the
formula and that's why uh we're actually
recording this by
not storing the clause here as reason at
all
in the implication analysis which i've
discussed before this just means you
have to check the level of a literal
like the decision level because uh like
levels uh variables which have a
decision level of zero should be skipped
okay then we'll assign the uh the
literals there's like
some other trick which is related to
that these
um you actually want to have
access to these values these values
array for each liter for each variable
um branchless and because of that we'll
actually
duplicate uh the value in a certain
sense we may we have in this array it's
not it's not a variable size but it's
actually of twice the size of the number
of variables
and it will access it with literals
which are twice the size of variables
right
and then for the negation where the the
least significant bit is
flipped you're put the minus one for
negative and you put
one for positive and it's zero by
default that means unassigned in the
video i had a dash for unassigned for
the number of variables
okay then
here you see three arrays which
do have are indexed by by the index of
the literal so this index macro here
really just
divides the literal by two and gets the
32 one
index bits right
and um
all right so first of all you remember
uh the sign so this is a trick it's
called face saving which we're going to
talk about later when we look at
decisions then we're going to um save
the reason of a clause
and that's remember like for
for uh for a root level will become zero
but but otherwise it's kind of the the
arrows in the the incoming arrows in
duplication graph
uh are represented by by this assignment
so this is really beautiful if you think
about it right so the implication graph
we saw
is a complicated graph structure and you
would wonder how do you really represent
this in the computer it's it's
completely trivial it's just take a
reference to the clause which forced
this literal to be
a site
now you might wonder what do you do with
the decisions well with decisions you do
the same they guarantee it not to be on
decision level zero okay
so this thing here is then not zero uh
but then the you keep just put the
reason which is zero and valid pointer
right now reference so you find
decisions by uh not having a reasons and
except for those variables which have
are assigned a decision level zero and
those are units
okay so these are uh this is we will
come back to this phase save this later
uh this thing i want to show you um
these are the um this is in essence the
information which is encoded in
duplication graph we just discussed so
the reasons are these uh kind of
um
incoming arrows for a literal
implication graph
because the reason contains of course
all the other literals and
also the implied rule
and um
this is the silver level right you need
that for multiple things like for uh as
i said like figuring out whether it's a
unit uh whether it's a decision
okay now comes something uh we put
something on the trail so this trade is
pre-allocated so that's why it's not a
really push
stack thing but we know that like the
trellis is maximum size of the number
variable so that's why we pre-allocated
and then then we'll put the
the literal which was just assigned
it was assigned to true right you still
see it here in this line on on the trail
uh okay then uh i want to mention this
already now
we also decrease the number the counter
which counts the number of unassigned
variables that gives us a very fast
check to determine whether the current
formula is satisfiable right so we don't
need to go through all clauses and
figure out what the satisfiable only we
were going to have a check like
which checks that the there are no
unassigned variables left and we
propagated everything and then this the
combination of these two properties will
let us conclude that the formula
uh is
satisfiable okay
so now um let's go to the um assign
function
sorry the analyze function which is um
exactly a corresponds to our
all right so we're going to um now um
look at um top down to the
analysis as i said right so here's the
the cdcs solving loop so you haven't
seen a girl actually pseudo code of that
yet but this is
very close to like how you would
represent it on slides as well uh so
first of all um you might already see
here this 20 which is the code for
unsatisfiability and that's like only
set to
if to the recite value if if the solver
happens to be inconsistent which is a
synonym for having learned an empty
clause or having an empty clause
like a original empty clause right
um otherwise we'll just have this loop
here and the first part of the loop you
will just um
really um to constrain propagation and
and again so we're going to look at that
also later so uh you will just walk all
the clauses of the freshly assigned
literals on the trail
and then
look through their
whether their unit or whether they're um
in conflict and
if they're in the conflict then we go to
this analysis
what we decide what we discussed if
they're actually in unit clauses then
we'll just make this assignment with the
function which we also just saw
and and continue okay
um and then this iterate flag this is
exactly the i we saw in the output so if
if you learn a unit then the server
would implicitly in in analysis actually
set this flag to true so that we can see
that in the output that there's a little
unit line so otherwise and that's what i
also mentioned before there's this
unassigned counter so if there are no
variables left anymore
and uh which are a sinus sign so in a
sense like the the trail is now as as
large as it is possible okay all the
variables are assigned
and uh propagation did not uh result in
the conflict because we get here in this
else branch here
then um we're all done right we know the
formula is satisfiable so we set this
and this will actually terminate this
loop here which
really continues until either the result
here is set to 20 for unsat or the
result is set for 10 here after normal
variables are assigned and no conflict
occurred
otherwise we do some more things
including like reduction which i already
mentioned like for reducing clauses um
also um restarting and then some other
thing is possible uh um at the end we'll
need to pick a variable that's done here
in this design so that's the cdcl loop
as it's not recursive you want to write
down this for this um
dpl it gets a little bit more tricky
it's also possible doing it very
similarly but
yeah it's slightly different
now um as i said the hotspot is here
and this is kind of really the core of
this um cdcl and i are going to show
uh how this works uh in uh not only the
platform now
in real code um
[Music]
now
analyze
and
it gets
the solver of course and uh conflict so
the conflict is the is the clause which
uh the propagation found to be empty
remember like um we had this in this
example so you're doing some propagation
and then there was like the one clause
which forced three to true and then the
other clause says oh that i'm false
and this fourth clause is now given as
an argument to this function
the goal is now to learn the clause and
also do the backtracking and the
assignment of the or the flipping of the
literal
uh the first uip will actually be
flipped
okay so we're first getting the the
conflict level and if that's conflict
level is zero okay so we can in conflict
on the root
level and then of course like just by
the units and everything which is in the
formula unit propagation alone would
give you a conflict so that means the
formula is unsung
but um well
we came to this point actually with
without having found this earlier so
we're now
marking this as unsaturated formula
and then uh we'll also ask the proof
checker actually to check this
but and because there's no other literal
edit to the learn
like the checker that would mean check
that the empty class is implied
okay then you see sort of there's like
um
three um data structures three uh three
um plot stacks actually needed here uh
one is the the the blocks um actually
each block is identified by the decision
level right we had like these blue
blocks or like that like three to one
like in one case it was only three one
so you could back jump to level one
then we would push actually one and
three here uh on this stack
and the second stack stack here this is
the clause we're learning obviously you
need to push these literals somewhere
before you really allocate claws
so there's a stack which does that
and then
this one here is kind of a marked bit
of
something similar to craft reversal of
the implication craft so this uh tells
you which of the
literals have i marked to to be seen and
the reason we need this is because we
need to undo these markings later
uh donald closing his solvers for
instance uses time spent to avoid this
sort of undoing of the marks unmarking
and and therefore doesn't need this
stack
okay then we make room for the first uip
so we want to keep the first erp as as
first element on the stack so we just
put sort of an invalid literal there is
a placeholder
then we get the marks again these marks
are these uh
flags which allow us to detect whether
we've seen already a literal in
duplication graph like as in craft
search right
and as you see these are signed charts
so these are just bytes so you have
bytes for every variable you have a byte
which tells you have i seen this
variable before and that's what you're
using for the marks then the levels we
saw that before when we in the
assignment so the levels of a literal
start in the pick array and we just
kind of
hope get that so they can easily refer
to it the same for the reason so these
are the the reasons we start doing
assignment right remember these two guys
actually uh really represent the
implication graph
and then for each decision level we have
another flag so similar to the variables
which is here we also remember which
which decision levels have been seen
already during the conflict analysis
right so these these guys are variables
and these are the decision levels and
then blocks here
this is just sort of um the
uh the
those frames which we have marked so the
blocks is in essence actually used to
unmark those bytes here which were used
to mark the decision levels which have
been seen
okay and then we start at the end of the
trail okay the trail is
almost like a stack uh so you saw that
in the assignment we pushed things onto
the trail like at the end so we start
there
and then and this is the trick we're um
having um
we count the number um of uh the
literals on the current level
in the clause we're kind of constructing
which are still unresolved initially
like all the literals in the conflicting
clause which are not from visual from
the decision level are uh unresolved
and
as i discussed before i made this
mistake right remember there that
usually there now there are
guaranteed to be two literals in the
current of the current decision level uh
in the conflicting clause
uh so this will be after we resolve
um after we start this whole thing with
the
conflicting clause will this number will
be at least two
and then we're going to sort of resolve
a way along the trail like starting
backward from this t here
and all the uh literals we found so far
until
this unresolved current level here is
zero and then we'll get the uap so
that's why here at the outside this is
kind of the outcome of this thing
there's a variable called uip again
unsigned and just encodes the literal
here
okay so we have a reason it's non-zero
so we're analyzing this the log function
will actually print the reason
marking this reason is used for
um like actually
reduction so we're not going to
um throw away used reasons
um
and then we go over the uh over the
claws you see here that
i'm using here
c but i have some macros in place which
almost make it look like uh
automatic ranges in c um
11 but
and therefore keep the um the code
actually compact so what i do here is
like i go over all these literals like
we saw this on the blackboard
of this reason clause then i'll get the
index
get the level of it
if the level of that literal is is zero
right i don't have to do anything we
this is i already explained also before
so the the solvers assume that
everything on decision level zero is
kind of ignored so you only remember the
values of these variables but nothing no
reasons the clauses are in how satisfied
which are these reasons
then i'll take the mark pit and the mark
bit is either z and seenism is just one
uh and or uh or not and if it's uh
marked then i have seen that and i can
ignore it otherwise i mark it as seen
and then later because i need to unmark
it i'll i'll push it here on the um
analyzed stack on the scene stack
actually
there is
some
necessary necessity to to start this
analyze stack later with respect to
timestamps
for the to keep the decisions in order
along the timestamps and that's why i
not only um push the index here the
variable index on this analyzed or scene
stack i i push with it also the
the time stamp with it but this is a
technology which we could discuss maybe
later
okay then um
we're analyzing this literal right um so
we're saying okay so this one has now
been seen
um and now we need to have a k split and
this case bit is like typical for for
cdcl if the literal is in a lower
decision level right so in in the
pictures i had that was where these
lines right and then we're resolving
below these lines here and if after
um if you now find the literal which was
above right from a high a lower decision
level then uh we're in this first case
uh otherwise if you're below then we're
on the current decision level
and if you're in the current decision
level
see what's happening well then we just
increase this
number of unresolved literals on the
current decision level
um
we've marked it as a side effect so
that's important and but we also need to
increase this number the second case
here when the literal is really like
from a lower decision level really means
we're going to learn this literal put
this into the clause we're going to
learn
that's what's happening here
all right just push this into well this
is one of the literals we're going to
put into our learn clause
uh note by the way this literal is is um
because it occurs in a reason of a
clause and it's not that we're going to
see the um the literal which is fourth
to true this will be only a literal
which is false to force you also see
here the assertion that this is
the case um that
is really sort of like the negation
already we're seeking right so we kind
of um
do here um
the negation um implicitly here
um right by falling in sort of an arrow
backward in the implication graph uh we
said okay we have to flip the literal
but but here because it this literally
is part of the reason it's already
flipped
uh then we do some uh bookkeeping here
for the levels as i said like also the
levels are
are a um
are marked the sort of decision levels
which are which are um
used and and these are called frames and
so if
if this
uh not marked yet then uh the
uh i need to pull in this uh decision
level i call it in other silver so you
pull in this additional and this is bad
right remember the example with the back
jumping
like every decision level you omit
uh helps you to sort of keep keep this
sort of the
the cross sparser that's also the idea
behind these glucose levels the number
of blocks right you want to keep these
blocks as as as few as possible and
that's why kind of this is not
if you have too many of these this is
kind of gives you bad like not that good
clauses
um but i want to count this anyhow so
i'll push this um
if it's not has not been seen yet this
level i push it on the on the blocks
right like the integer number level is
pushed on the plug and it's marked as
being used
all right now uh this
is the end here of going over all
literals
of the reason and
we'll just have this
this
conflicting clause here is is is a
reason uh assigned here
where is it here so we just take the
through this loop
which goes backward over the trail we'll
just
have
the conflict as reason so this is kind
of a misnomer because we're
it's a conflicting thing so everything
is false in it
later the reason will always be a reason
for forcing a variable to be true and it
will be the case then that this
list variable or this literal here is um
is has already been seen before so
that's why it will not be pushed and
that's why this uh um like a search and
i was just mentioning here is true
because the literal which was assigned
to true uh was already marked to be seen
before and so we're not getting here
because we're
the mark was true
okay now um
comes the part with the sort of
topological sorting it's kind of hitting
here in this loop
so we're now at the particular trail
position right and um but this trail
maybe the the very last variable rate
might actually not have might have sort
of be assigned even after um the
conflict um
uh lean variable because we're sort of
like way earlier in propagating we have
not reached the end of the trillion in
our propagation
um and so i'm going into the
trail and checking whether this little
was already seen and it has not been
seen well and i just keep on going
backward in the trail until i find
those literals from the from the claws
and and will um
and will um
[Music]
will um
mark i will will take it then so this
loop terminates
um if i find uh such a literal which has
been seen
okay and it's actually guaranteed here
uh this is what this assertion says that
you will never go
oh
never have an underflow you will always
be above the trail and we'll talk about
this later anyhow so you this is the
next uap candidate here so it's like a
candidate at this point so you don't
know yet it becomes really they can the
uip if the number of unresolved literal
and the current decision level really
drops to uh to zero right because then
this one was the last one we
resolved away and then we break out of
this loop otherwise we know or this
thing needs to have a reason
why well it cannot be a decision because
the decision is of course a uip so p
would be the decision of this decision
level then it's guaranteed that this
thing here is um
is zero um after res um and
uh
uh because of that uh your will go out
on of this loop
okay then we found our unique
implication point you can actually get
there some nice log message for this one
uh then that's what i already said like
we need to um instead of the place where
we we
we made room for for putting the the uip
uh that's uh the first literal in the
clause that's now overwritten with the
just found a uip
uh and then we can lock the the claws we
actually did use
um and then comes something i'm not sure
like i have time for that in in this
video here
which is called plus minimization we
start with this clause and actually we
can shrink it uh and the shrinking goes
also uses um the the implication graph
and then you get like often a smaller
class which is um
at least as good as the the originally
deduced clause here
okay now you see also um
it makes also very simple the definition
of of blocks so the the the blocks are
the the number of blue numbers we had
actually not completely true at the in
the slide like you had like maybe the
the the blue number three uh two one in
the blackboard in in three was sort of
the the current decision level that one
of those cost doesn't count so the
number of blocks is because the current
decision level is always a part of it
will always be seen in the conflict
right because you just made an
assignment on that level so that you
take out and and then you
take the other blocks like the other
levels which which have been seen that
which are stored in this block stack and
this is your glucose level
okay then we need to find the jump level
so once again what's the the jump level
was the second largest level in this
among those
blue ones including the current level
right so you go through this uh
um
through your um blocks and you find the
the second largest uh one that's why
what we have here right so it's a level
which is not the conflict level and
where the jump level is
smaller
okay then there is some um
metrics which have to do with restarting
which we also are going to discuss and
and then um
that's almost it except for one thing
which we have not discussed at all and
this will be part
of the second video which is how do we
actually pick decisions and that's
what's happening here so we're kind to
bump uh the levels involved in this
analysis and as you'll
kind of see it's
completely clear what you do and all the
variables i have seen there during this
kind of backward resolution to the
implication graph
those are important variables in my
current state of the search and those i
will going to make more important for
decisions and that's called bumping and
we'll discuss this next week in the next
part
otherwise i just backtracked to the uh
to the jump level this there's nothing
else but just unroll uh like shrinking
the trail i've been popping literals
from the trail until you that the top
most literal on the trail has this trump
level
okay and then i'll learn the clause
and the size of the clause is of course
needs to be again um
split into two cases the first case is
that the
the the learner unit and then um well
you don't need to learn a clause you
just assign this uh
to the uh at the root level so that's
why
jumping back to the root level uh then
we do our
nice uh um
prepare our nice output of the i column
right remember ci right this is done
here because we learned the unit uh and
we learn um this uh
not uip but i didn't say that before but
the
not you have p so it has to you have to
flip the erp because you take the uip
from the trail
and on the trailer only true literals
but of course you um
you want to put the negation of it into
the uh in the learn clause while for the
other clause the variables right which
are part of the reason which are all
false
uh those you put directly into the
learned clause
okay now um
now there's like some uh some
important sort of like things regarding
um watching schemes which we also
briefly touch upon later and um
but i'll i don't have time to explain
explain this here then we have to watch
the clause
and then reset everything
okay so this was a force uh
to default through
the analysis function and next
we're going to talk about
decisions
now back to the blackboard for for
so decisions um
actually uh come in two flavors and um
the the first one is
um and um
the second one is uh
which face uh silva yabu and the other
one is the face so so um this is already
of course um
um kind of heuristic
and it is the current one which is
employed in in in the source so um
and i'm going to um
um
explain both of them of course like
these are uh heuristics because
we don't really have um
any proofs on on how to use things here
um and
right so you need to pick a variable in
the face and already separating these
two is is is is an assumption
um
there's like one rule of thumb which is
a maximize um
satisfied clauses maximize uh
satisfied clauses
and um
the alternative to that is of course
kindly and uh and then why is that well
will because um
if you're if you're um trying to
get with the decision as many clauses as
possible satisfied you're getting closer
to a satisfying assignment and if you're
done right
if you reach this satisfying assignment
then you're done
and therefore like
trying to eagerly make big steps towards
this goal um it's guaranteed to to
either get you into sort of a dead end
or soon or
you're um
um you really find this a satisfying
assignment
and um
yeah related to this one is is
propagate as much as possible um
that's uh particularly interesting in
the old look ahead so where's where sort
of like uh you count uh if i make a
decision you count how many uh
additional variables would that actually
assign so in a certain sense you're
doing the same um
ego um kind of uh
forward-looking thing by um
um kind of actively um
actively um
uh kind of going for that um the so
these are kind of the the the two
heuristics in look ahead there's also
really like that's the name look ahead
that you kind of um simplify the formula
first so you do this sort of in a
two-step
approach
now the interesting thing about this is
now um this is not state-of-the-art
anymore so what we're doing is is called
um some people call it relevance based
decision heuristics
and with relevance here we mean um
your your look uh what and was actually
currently
uh important
and important obviously in close
learning are those literals which you
resolve away as we've just seen these
are the scene literals like these which
are pushed um on the scene stack during
the analysis those literature results
why well because they were always they
were used in a certain sense to revive
facts and um
and maybe um
and and this got us into a big
controversy is uh uh but i nevertheless
write it down here uh
this has a flavor of local search for
proof straight
and in particular if you drop the proofs
part here then i'll get into fight with
uh karem sakala and others um but i
think this is true so these relevance
the
decision heuristics and
uh these it's uh uh it's uh um
exponential version of it it's called
evsits and um
the thing i'm going to show you in code
is vmtf they are all um of these flavors
so you're taking what uh kind of the the
reasons for for things which went wrong
right and and you're trying
and to uh to um
actually focus on these things
which you um which went wrong recently
this is a very kind of a human way of of
of making decisions right
um
okay so let me um explain this in in
more uh details so we're going to do
um first
visits
i think now i can remember it's its
variable
score
independent i'll talk about that in a
minute
uh
dk
and then forgot was
s means
some
all right so the uh some so the sum
means uh that you sum it up over kind of
all literals
and and this comes from the um
um
[Music]
from old kind of papers from the 90s and
like what uh people used in cresp um
here's some you can't read it and um
this independent means that you're
really uh looking at variables rate as
it's kind of um
redundant this uh this
term because you're having here um
uh this independence sorry this
independent here and in this variable
are kind of um
um
are um our kind of synonyms
um all right so um
let me uh get a get rid of this one and
so what is this real uh so your
you kind of
[Music]
increase score
score of
uh scene variables this is already the
the modern version
in the old days uh when this paper in
2000 by
the friends from um
uh princeton uh came around um they did
it like uh
this was um here um
uh originally was like the variables in
the clause right
uh but um nowadays it's
um
it's the um
the
the scene variables
uh and actually actually more so um
and
a plus uh
reason literals and this goes back to
the maple silver's reason literals
um
[Music]
from canada plus recent literals um
uh of uh class literals
all right so this is kind of the state
of the art now so as you know what scene
is from the code um so you just do your
kind of travels with the craftable
graph and whenever you need to sort of
like go back
through
such an edge
you mark this new variable as seen and
that's like a variable which is
important
then at the end you have these variables
in the clause they are they have all
been seen by definition right but
there's some more like those which you
walked over
uh in on the current decision level and
then this uh like class reason these
roles here um
it's called also a reason side pumping
or bump reasons
this is kind of new from 2016.
[Music]
but
this
thing here um this means a decay and
that's really the important
also
decay
i would call it smooth
score
of all variables
um
right so what you really do in in one
conflict step is increase the score of
those variables which are involved the
relevant variables and then decay the
score of everybody
and this usually goes in
an exponential way
um sorry this would be only here there's
also support variable in
and this has very
very much to do with kind of um
an exponential moving average rate or um
which is of course a very um
uh common technique in
uh machine learning
and so the score of the video will
become um
actually uh the the old score of the
variable uh plus sorry this was exactly
no it's right plus alpha which is the
kind of smoothing and this is the um
decay here um
times the um like uh what you um you you
uh predict um sorry what you got which
is det sorry the data i'll come back to
that in a minute uh the delta and uh the
the
prediction
and now of course i got it wrong so
so this is um
here um
now this is exactly
the right formula
okay now what's this delta here uh
so this delta here is
the
um whether you actually saw that um
whether um
[Music]
this is a relevant variable so you
compute this score update for all
variables right this s prime is done for
all variables but then uh you
distinguish with this data those
variables which are
seen and which are not seen and and and
and for this uh um
scene here uh delta is um
a one for scene uh um
variables and and zero
otherwise and of course you need to take
this uh
reason side here uh also into account
they would come become kind of reason or
recent site
okay and uh this data
um
you can so so from this uh
equation down here you you see this this
is a
kind of um
an update um of the um
of this course
um
and then um so you can think of like all
variables go down actually exponentially
with a smooth go to to zero and the um
then those variables which kind of are
interesting they pick out and and that
was the v6
okay now the
visit says this issue
that you're
that you're i'm going to um
have
um
to update all the scores
right as i explained i guess prime has
to be computed for all variables uh this
is costly we can have millions of
variables every conflict we're going
through all millions variables and
uplink this is pretty like it's still in
the formula but gives you kind of a
quadratic sort of flavor
thing
and
that's why um
people came up with e-sits actually too
many many sad authors nicholas in and
nicholas silvansen
and and they um
have this um
kind of the
number sorry the number of uh scene
variables is way smaller than the number
of variables right and and this is the i
command that maybe we can have an error
everything which only updates scores of
the scene variables and so what they do
is actually
your um
add
[Music]
increment
to
to all
scene variables
um exponentially kind of
in a geometric fashion
uh in uh um maybe i should put here the
name of this increment so this is kind
of maybe um
uh
what kind of yeah well well let's call
it um capital i
uh and then i prime uh becomes um
um something um like like
um actually what you what you would
would do would be
1 over
1 minus alpha
times i
um
so this is in machine learning usually a
beta like a
number close to one while alpha is very
small and
uh so this is kind of
usually a number like uh close to one
but above one so typically uh
uh
for instance right one point white for
instance
and beta would be uh zero point one
and
alpha would be then
0.1
okay this
explains kind of how things work so you
kind of um
instead of decreasing everybody by 10
what you do is you increase the bump
um this is called then bump actually so
maybe i should have called it b
uh pump increment
you bump this uh every time more
exponentially more uh of course the
problem then is that once in a while
actually
quite frequently after maybe thousand
conflicts you run out of um
uh you overflow here and in particular
uh you uh which is
initially when i saw this is this is
awkward
but nowadays um
i don't think it's an issue anymore also
because compilers become more robust
with respect to floating point uh you
need floating points right and then you
have typically um 10 to the power 10 e
150 is kind of the limit where where the
thing overflows
and then what you just do is while you
take this biggest score and divide all
the variable score by this this biggest
one
um so this was one of the invention of
the necklaces the other one is
well you need a binary heap priority
queue where you put these scene
variables um
okay
and um then you always pick from this
bayern
the priority queue uh the variable which
is um
um
the top variable with the largest score
and
however that of course has the problem
that
you can only uh make decisions on
variables which are unassigned uh and
and therefore um
in original implementations by offenses
alex nadel and also by myself
you would would have
always eagerly removed all assigned
variables like those which are
propagated from the
binary heap so that the binary heap only
contains the priority contains only the
unassigned variables but that's pretty
costly if you remember so you do one
decisions and then maybe 10 or even 100
propagation so you need to sort of
remove all these 100 literals from this
binary heap which is still each of them
a log n operation
yes therefore nicholas silvanson had
this idea well why don't we do this
lazily so we keep all the elbows on the
heap
and
as soon we ask for
a decision we
pop from the heap of the maximum with
the maximum score and we find the
variable which is unassigned and when
you sign that one
of course then doing backtracking by
unassigning the variables
you need to check whether these
variables are not on the heap and then
push them back
okay this is the exponential visits and
this is i would like what everybody
else does nowadays except
for
my always where i use a variant at least
like in some part of the code which is
variable move to front and that's uh
much much easier uh to to
um
explain and i'll explain this one next
and also the implement and that's why i
want to show you this
in more detail
so now uh to um this vmtf or variable
move to front and
so variable
move
to front
so this
was first
appeared first in the siege sets over
but has
a pretty like um um
like old concept which is this move to
front
um basically uh instead of using a
binary heap
which is a part of um and also this is
the smoothing this decay thing we're
using something much more aggressive i
would say
and uh always keeps it like the
very most recent um variable which was
involved in producing conflict uh as our
highest priority for making decisions so
how how is this done well it's it it's
very simple so here we're doing also um
we keep the variables in a w linked list
keep variables
in a
doubly
linked list
okay
and
[Music]
okay scene variables um are taken out
and move to the end
move to the end uh now the only thing
which i still need to say is a search
from the end
uh towards uh maybe this search from
from um um to
which you call this head and
well and from end to beginning uh to uh
for a decision from end to beginning
for a decision
okay
um now this has a
slightly quadratic uh
uh flavor right so you're whenever you
make a decision you're
you're uh need to sort of start from the
end uh searching from getting so it's
like uh um
[Music]
uh unless you can sort of hope that sort
of like the variables you you need to
make decisions on are kind of always
staying at the end of the the list this
this is
this sounds uh
bad and uh
and also the original um
author um uh ryan uh who uh for this
from the sats over siege
[Music]
uh
didn't um figure that out but in 2015 we
wrote a paper on how you how you um can
do this implement this faster
and um i explain this now this is with
uh
stamps so everything i had on the uh
before i erased it is of course also
true so we're we're um
keeping the verb doubly linked list like
like we remove variables which are seen
and put them at the ad and also we
search but um we're um keeping um
a search as cache
so so what that means is is
when we search the list we remember um
up to which point we researched right so
maybe um we found like um
a variable and
and um
uh
uh and
and then we remember like the position
the list where we stopped the search for
for variable and then when we again then
start searching for decision we started
the position
and this already looks like better why
because uh well if you think about like
you have like 10 000 um
sort of like uh literals right so so
this is my list even so it looks like a
stack and um
right and and yeah and these are like
one a
let's say even
500 a hundred thousand uh variables
right
and then i make a decision here and then
i make a decision here and if i always
start here from the beginning here here
at the end
and here's the beginning
uh to find a new variable like i'm
traversing here and checking whether
these variables are
unassigned then of course like i have
accumulated like already cost if there's
no conflict happening right so for
instance if you would have um
a cnf
if really um like this um
this queue here has one and it goes like
maybe 200 000 right
and
you really have uh only one clause in
your dynamics format which looks like
this right
and um
so p
c f
100 000 uh
one
uh then um you see what's going to do
right so i'm going to go over this list
like in a quadratic way right so i go
from the right and then i such again
and the obvious uh solution for that is
of course this is this search thing
right so you were just going to um have
here um
a search field which is um uh um
this this one here and we're having um
um
like we just uh remember
um the position actually in the code
we're going to remember the variable
because there's a
mapping from the from the variables to
the positions um in the in this uh
doubly linked list and um
okay and then when i need to do the
um
sort of like
pick a decision then i move my search
pointer to a next position
okay that looks uh
simple but now comes the problem uh what
if um
i have to um
backtrack
and in particular um unassign
unassign a variable rate and it could be
that for instance your uh your search
here is uh
as we have here in the picture right uh
um so it's uh um it's it's here
and um
but um
there's like maybe the variable um
17 here which is unassigned
unassigned this guy
uh
then of course this search is wrong
right
because
you'll need to make sure like all the
the most important variables are to the
right and you need to sort of find the
first most important rate so this is the
um like um importance order to the right
is more important right so so this is
most important
and you want to pick the decision which
is most important
um
okay
now how do you do that well one way
would be um is it's also not described
in literature well whenever you
backtrack just uh
put the search here uh to the end right
so you could doing back tracking just
put it here during backtracking
but then again you don't avoid this
quadratic uh
example i showed you right with that 100
000 clauses
um okay so what um our solution was in
the 2010 point is to have here um a kind
of a list of
stems okay
um and these are um timestamps
where i'm sorry at
uh timestamps where um your um kind of
make sure that they ordered uh along the
enqueue time so you can sort of think of
this is
timestamps uh or um
nq time
the time when you enqueued something to
the right right
and um yeah and this should be of course
like uh uh be uh
totally uh ordered right so like s
thousand three five and
um and so on thousand um
um yeah whatever
okay now the point is you know that this
search here put has the has the times
then four but i'm going to unassign here
uh this variable 17 and then i'm looking
up here the timestamp of the variable
and if this is uh bigger than then uh
this one i are going to destroy it and
move the
the search
here right
yeah and that's it
okay this uh empirically so i don't have
a
theoretical analysis is really
very fast as it's way faster
to um
then actually the code runs faster than
the
the binary heap code
it's
also um
[Music]
easier to implement actually because you
don't have to implement the binary heap
maybe more to this um
offline but like you need to integrate
this heap into the in the south server
for instance the standard priority queue
in an stl doesn't have an update minimum
because you need to
search they always work with minimum uh
so you need to pop up with during update
like we compute our scores prime all the
literals so you need to probably
implement your binary um q heap yourself
it's not that a big deal but
still and um
yeah and then um the the the
unassignment in this case is really
constant time i mean the search might
increase but the unassignment is
constant time you just take out like in
this case for instance you would take
out the
if it's bumped right you take out the 17
and you move it to the end
and
you might need to update this search
pointer while in the um
with binary heaps really so if you have
to
even until you use this lazy trick i
mentioned you have to push back like to
the binary heap all these uh variables
which are um which become um
which were taken lazily like uh from
this uh
from the heap they need to go back and
and this is really like a a login
operation uh every time and if you have
a million variables that's still quite
substantial if you have to sort of push
back like 10 or 20 hundred or something
okay there's still like one issue sold i
mean this thing as i've said already
this is really aggressive okay
what do i mean with aggressive and um
well if you think about it like um the
the factors we discussed before um so we
had like a beta was uh 0.9 right or
alpha 0.1
um
they could in principle simulate such a
variable move to front queue
with the actually alpha
equal beta equals 0.5 right
this is gives you almost the same effect
except and that's like
if you do this with the buying of a heap
you will just increase the pressure on
this binary way more things will be
bubbled up and probably down
the the binary heap then with a smoother
uh
decision
like a smoother um
decay like with 0.1 or even 0.01
okay so so it's not advisable to
simulate the variable move to front with
a
binary heap
um
okay that's uh one issue right so you
cannot really do that on the other hand
it turns out that for satisfiable
instances
you should not really be aggressive so
you should kind of
accumulate
the knowledge about which variables are
interesting and not just really focus on
the most recent ones
i mean this is intuition there's no
proofs or something here but this is uh
kind of um
what's important for satisfiable
instances once again in satisfyments it
seems that you want to be sort of more
stable and that's also why the solvers
my solvers have um and also like stains
transit or silvers have a stable and and
like a focused phase i call it now of
focused mode where you switch between
the two and in the stable mode you're
better off using a non-aggressive um
sort of like very
low alpha
decision queue and in this case you
cannot should not use vmtf
but in the other phase in the focus
phase which is particularly important
for
unsatisfied instances uh almost let's
put it this way for very very hard um
um
satisfied with this maybe two then um
your or you should be extremely
aggressive and localize the the
the proof search as much as possible and
that's what you get by the mtf and in
addition you get also the benefit that
the
actual implementing heuristic is cheaper
than with this doubly linked list than
with the
with the binary heap if you use um this
stamping trick i i just
explained
okay we're going to look now at the code
for the stamping
um so first of all there's like this is
just a standard implementation of
of the doubly linked list now um with
instead of pointers we're just using the
variable indices as
next in previous
fields right
this not only um yeah this makes it a
little bit more uh faster so you do the
voids um
like eight pipe so it only needs like a
four byte uh instead of eight pi
and also we can resize this this link
array without sort of fixing pointers
if we increase the number of variables
of the software
and beside this sort of classical
previous next fields you have this
timestamp by discuss so this is the
timestamp when this variable if it's on
the queue was an enqueued ring
and the the queue itself looks like this
so we have the first and last as a head
and tail if you want of the uh
of the queue
yeah i call this begin here the first
and called the last
end so this is where we start searching
towards the first one
this is the position of the
this is the variable which we found last
in our search
uh during searching for a decision and
and
and when we research more to the left to
the um less important variables then we
update that so that next time we search
we don't need to start again from the
end and then this stamp here this is the
the timestamp which
is the number of times i include
something on onto the variable of course
this is as you see i've also put this
into like four bytes like just a roughly
after four billion um
stamp operation this will overflow and
then we need to call this a restamp
operation
and um yeah so the overflow happens down
here and this wisdom there's nothing
else but going over that uh
link and then really just put um
like fixing the
the stamps that's that that everything
on the queue is in on or in order again
and then really just because this
happens so rarely like really only every
like four billion times uh we'll just
put um
the the search cache here uh to the end
and and well the empty queue is empty
now now here this is where this happens
as i said like the
the
time stamp there is a for byte like 32
bit integer like after four billion
times steps or so to the power like 32
it will overflow uh but in it's an
unsigned so it's like in c actually um
well defined and and uh
then um
we will go here into the second part
where we raise them otherwise we'll just
do um
this following check uh we that whether
this uh literal we enqueue is actually
uh unassigned and if it's unassigned
sorry if it's unassigned and if it's
unassigned we of course need to update
the the search pointer to to the end
um
okay this the dq version does not any of
the special code for handling
this and now we can go to the actual
pumping
all right so this is the code we saw
before already and
it's really the scene stack this is this
again these are the variables which we
see during conflict analysis
and plus optionally not in this code but
in other solvers you can also pump the
literals in the reasons of
the the variables in the in the learning
clause which is actually good idea um
and
then you're just bumping what is really
bumping in well it's just dequeuing all
these uh variables from the queue this
is a constant time operation and then
queuing it right
um this is not for the bumping this is
just for unmarking the um sort of like
scene variables
okay that's almost it so there's like
one catch though which um
is um maybe yeah this is like something
you pay for for this
um
using the vmtf it turns out that the
basic scheme i just explained is is um
can be improved and it actually
unfortunately substantially improved by
making sure that when you take out these
variables right
like maybe these guys uh and and then
you put them to the end right then
you're you you you put them in the same
order you don't reverse them right you
put them in the same order actually it
is even more clear if these are kind of
interleaved you take them out in the
order and you put them here at the end
and
this really gives the boost
heuristically so the risky gets better
right it's nothing with sort of the the
time spent in this update it's not the
university gets better it's important it
seems to be that you should keep the
yellow black in the same order
as they are kind of the keeping the the
order stable which is a little bit
counter intuitive to the idea of
aggressive
bumping with vmtf
okay and well that's why you need to um
you should actually assort these
analyzed um
variables with their stamp uh time stamp
time and um you saw this before um
this is where uh there uh why uh here in
the conflict analysis we're not uh only
pushing the variable index on this stack
of of scene variables but unless this
macro and sword here is true
where it's disabled this sorting
it's but also the timestamp and then
we'll assert these pairs of in variable
index and time stems
with
with uh with respect to the timestamp
okay and then we bump uh of course as
you can see after it's started here
we're we're really going from the
smallest uh
timestamp and and take that out one
first and put it at the end
and so on right so you always keep sort
of the relative order between these guys
intact
so
this is the implementation
of
vm
tf so let's go back to the
cdcl loop um and um so what you know
understand now by now is this pulling
constraint propagation we looked at
analyze this iterate was of course this
is this minor thing for printing this
eye and what are what are the two things
which are like sort of in all
all silver um missing and are important
are this restarting so you only get into
this restarting
if
if you didn't find the conflict through
publication and there's still unassigned
variables left so in principle you would
want to use this decide down here but at
this point you can also decide to to
restart unless it's again with the macro
uh disabled or um
it's uh um yes the switching which you
have not discussed or and or this uh
deducing uh reducing the the the
database okay
so decide we've covered yet and we're
going to do now the restarting
um so restarting is really comes from a
completely different sort of like
motivation in local search
it was shown in the end of last century
that like if you run um
say
anything which is kind of a random
component for a while you might get
stuck in sort of an unlucky situation
and while on average it's actually
possible to reach the goal fast and
because of that it's good not to get
sort of like stuck in that situation but
to kind of restart and
and this way proceed
the interesting thing is that the the
motivation today is completely different
and uh we haven't completely understood
that part yet
but like there's empirical evidence that
is exactly the opposite so has nothing
to do with with search
um
in the sense of
the assignment space however it might
still have the same motivation if you
think in terms of
sort of local search for proof
and you might end up sort of like
focusing too much on this way of proving
something and maybe there's another way
and therefore you should have a chance
to to um to restart
okay restarting itself is pretty simple
so let's have a look um
at that one first that's uh very simple
so which is backtrack backtrack to
decision level zero what i have not
implemented yet maybe
until a couple of days later is um
something which marvin hoyle and
students came
like
figured out which was
reusing the trail and then sometimes you
don't need to backtrack really to the
top so the second argument to backward
is that maybe you remember it was the
jump leveling and that analyze so here
it's the
zero of course you go just really to the
back um why is this not harmful you
might uh argue well because we don't do
anything else so we only backtrack right
so we keep all the learned clauses we in
particular keep the
the the scores of the variables
and and now uh comes uh
another part we're kind of here
in the default situation so this has to
do with the switching which we're
probably going to um explain later um
you're really increasing this interval
between two um two restarts how are
these intervals measured well they
measured in the number of conflicts so
you see it here so this is the limit for
the restart and it's set to the current
number of conflicts
um so you saw this was in one of the
columns
plus this interval and this interval
here
that's
actually here
has a slightly increase here in his log
and in in classical silver this would be
a geometric or arithmetic um
but since glucose
people actually get kind of a constant
interval and why this is possible we'll
discuss
uh in a second um
yep in stable mode we'll use a more
classical one but i'll talk about this
later right that's so that's really all
this is like what happens in restarting
you see you in essence just backtrack to
the
um
to the root
uh and uh well you try and next restart
some insert uh restart interval again so
like uh if you spend like a thousand
restart this is locked in actually here
um rounded up um then you're having like
an interval of three and so on okay
um
the interesting part here is not like
what you do but
when you do it
okay so that you remember in the cdc
loop code there was this if restarting
then restart so so this is the
restarting function the trigger when you
restart
okay so you do don't restart if it's the
decision level 0 because you're already
there uh then you check this limit so so
this kind of says okay the the rest of
this code is never crooked if you
haven't hit this limit so you wait at
least for a couple of conflicts
but not that money right so yeah as i
told you right so like
maybe three or four
okay then um
comes something completely uh um
a little or it's it's maybe obscure but
it it can be explained um and that's
like the main purpose of of this part of
the video
so we're going to check the average clue
and that means like just the glue of the
clauses which um
i've learned recently so there's an
exponential moving average behind that
and i'll talk about that in a in as in a
minute and we have two uh such
exponential moving averages a fast one
um and a slow one and um
maybe i'll show this um on on on the um
uh blackboard um so you can think of
this as
like in stock market analysis so so so
if you have here uh the time right
and um
and here's the price
then what people do in stock market
analysis they they measure like a slow
moving average like something like that
right
so this is a slow moving average
while uh of course like the view data
like look looks like that right
i'm not sure i got it right so this is
slow moving average and
and then they do another one which is uh
you see a a small uh um
isn't like the actual data right but
it's like uh like uh
a faster moving average than the uh then
this low one so this is a
fast moving air here at the end i didn't
get it right
okay
um and then in addition they would
have um a margin around this thing where
sort of you say okay so
before i have here an event which which
forces something i want to see a margin
and um
okay so the events are of course
these places where these two lines cut
right so here and and here and in here
uh and here and and here but
and then in stock markets you would
sell uh if uh yeah like here in this
event here
because um it's uh
uh like the long average like the lower
um like low move fast moving average
seems to go over the long average moves
so people are selling so it's it's
likely that the trend will continue uh
and you do the opposite so like if uh if
uh here for instance like maybe a couple
of days later where
um
uh you're um you're cutting again this
line and and and then it's the opposite
so of course like my my my drawing here
is not accurate um but just get the
point right so you have this fast moving
average and and maybe to make this more
concrete i think in stock market
analysis they really like six or nine
days window and i'll explain it in a
second of um
um
uh of computing the averages over the
last six days for instance this is
computing it over a month
and and this is um
like a real average like in this window
what you can also do is an exponential
moving average so it has exactly this
formula we saw before for the variable
for the
exponential visits
where you then do the alpha is just one
over the days right uh and so if you
have for nine days it's like uh
one over nine and um
and for for 30 days it's one over 30 and
and and then because this alpha actually
gives you the correction of the current
score in that case here it's uh um
it's like maybe i write down this this
function again
it's like uh plus uh alpha times now uh
this would be your kind of uh price and
and this would be your current value
now uh like the fast version would be um
one over nine while the these this low
version here would be one over let's say
29 days or whatever
um and um okay so this is how you can
compute it without a window and we're
going to do this also in the sat solver
and
i think i'll have
um
like one alpha alpha fast here is
one over um sorry
0.03
in the um um alpha's low
was if i'm not mistaking zero zero zero
zero one or something so we look in the
code to make this precise but in this
order right so this was like a
three um
e
minus
2 and this guy would be
e minus 5.
okay um
okay so the rule is if if the if the
glue measured this way
is um reasonably so you take a margin
actually the margin
is um like some percentage of the the
slow moving um price or the slow moving
clue if the slow moving
clue plus some sort of fraction
is lower than the a fast moving cloud
then it seems the clue is going up fast
and then that's not a good sign and then
we restart that's the idea
uh and that kind of
allows empirically to sort of control
the
the the point where you want to restart
in and do only restarts where you not
like in the pigeon really making
progress that the glue goes down
and you really sort of like seeing okay
so this is strange i'm a situation where
i'm going up and up and up and maybe i
should really restart and see whether i
can find
kind of more locally uh the proofs
with
with restarting
okay now let's go back um to the code
and and see what is happening right so
so here you see um the unbiased um fast
moving average we'll go looking into
this function soon then here's the slow
moving one so this is just like um
in the previous picture the uh the the
two um averages the the the um the white
one and the um
green one and then we're multiplying
this thing by a factor like one point
two five actually and then we'll get um
the um
[Music]
the limit so let's maybe start
looking for this constants because i
promised this before right so here you
see um the the restart mars marching is
1.5 as i said like if you're 25 over the
the slow moving glue average with a fast
low moving average then you restart
and then this is the as i also like head
on this on the blackboard three
times and 10 to the power minus
two
and the fast moving averages is actually
a slow moving
the alpha for the slow moving average is
defined here now um yeah what about this
unbiased thing so this is something i
figured out um recently
by reading some machine learning papers
and um it turns out that these
exponential moving averages are are
really um
um
are are brittle in the sense that they
are biased towards the initial value and
of course we start with zero so this
means that for instance the slow moving
clue rate it would really ramp up very
slowly to sort of the real
average and you want to fix that and in
our paper where we described this first
also in 2015 how we do this
and also like in catechol implementation
we didn't figure out a nice way of doing
it i have to say at least no
theoretically justified but there's like
a nice paper machine learning paper
actually famous machine learning papers
which is about the
the atom um
[Music]
method for for for learning meta
parameters and part of that is a section
where they talk about initializing
exponential moving averages and so what
they simply do is
you remember better it's just one minus
alpha they um
they multiply the computed exponential
average with this term and then that
they they've given analysis which of
course is a little bit too above my
limit of understanding of the
statistical parts the claim is that an
unbiased uh um and it it really looks
pretty good so i looked empirically and
legally much better than the solutions i
have before and what you see is really
sort of like the the exponential sort of
like without any uh of this
initialization this thing this expansion
will wiggle a lot and actually overshoot
like what you really it should be
with this thing it really very fast
triggers on the um kind of intuitively
visually the the writing in
exponential moving average
um yep and this is the formula uh we saw
before you see in c it's even simpler
than on the blackboard
so
it is still here right this blue one
and
it's exactly the same
weiss didn't see easier because we have
this plus equal here but otherwise it's
exactly the same and then here's the
unbiased one well you'll probably want
to catch this one over
minus beta to the power n right because
that's expensive to compute these are
floating points and this one um this is
just done by keeping better um caching
better off
over n where n is the number of updates
to this exponential moving average next
time we do which is multiply this cashed
value by beta which is of course here
it's like even pre-con computed as a
constant
okay uh and that computes these averages
and um
um
yeah for the restarts and let me just
mention here
john czecho made this observation i
think i mentioned this already before
that you have you should you keep your
silver
into two modes
uh one which
is more um sort of has many restarts and
one which has less restarts and the
later is actually good for satisfiable
instances while the form is good for
unsatisfiable as i said it's the
completely opposite as the original
motivation maybe except for this point
with the proof search i made that maybe
the same argument from back then applies
to proof search where you sort of like
should switch to um like new parts of
the search base um
okay um so
and how do you keep this um
apart uh well the current code does this
uh s pyramid in keysight so you measure
in some sense the virtual time spent in
the in the focused mode the focus mode
is the one where you kind of
attractively restart with this glucose
[Music]
style um
restarts but with exponential moving
average which i just explained this
would be this else part here
and otherwise if you're in the stable
mode right which is only enabled if uh
mode switching is actually compiled in
then uh you're doing a slower um restart
um scheduling and in this side and
category i'm using the lubi um schedule
schedule maybe some of you know that one
here because i was too lazy to implement
it the lubi or donald luther reluctant
dublin version of it i just fall back to
my old picasa inner and outer scheme
which actually for instance is still
used in in my copy here of z3
which you will figure out if you um
enable the bose mode
okay so this inner outer um works by
kind of going up to a sort of the outer
limit and you go
down and you start again the in the
minute exponential up as like more like
a sawtooth change but it's like an
exponential increasing
sawtooth chain and the
inner outer factor here gives you the
sort of the increase exponentially in
the original papers this 1.1 and the
current implementation is actually 2.2
okay so these are then the modes of
restart which the which means like far
less free starts in
in the stable mode now the question is
still like when do you uh switch the
mode
and as i try started to explain uh this
is happening here so um
the the standard this all starts with
the focused mode so it will be in this
line and always check them so then it's
conflict control and these conflicts
will increase like in in a arithmetic
way and then during this time where
you're kind of in
in focused mode you compute the
number of ticks uh this is the sort of
similar to knuth memory
uh so it's kind of a virtual time to
measure how much time did you spend here
in
in the focus mode since the large switch
rate and then uh next time you run then
in stable mode you're um trying to use
the same number of tips why don't you
use this the conflicts well it turns out
that in instead in in focused mode
because you're restarting so
aggressively you your your conflict rate
per second goes dramatically down here i
saw cases with where this was a factor
of 20.
and so measuring the um the the
conflicts and using the conflicts is not
good because then you spend sort of like
10 times more time in in in the focused
mode and it's not what you want
so that's why um kind of we're giving
here um the limits
the conflicts limit for the for the
focused mode and then use the ticks
computed in that
as a limit for the
for the stable mode and that's the
similar actually uh switching between
um
stable and achieve happens here stable
and
focused mode which is in in kisa now
this is simpler here but otherwise it
has a kind of the the same uh part
um i want to show you this also um
running so we need to then
a slightly larger example let's try um
the
speakers formula which is in the
uh repository this one and and um
so um
let me
scroll up here to show you this uh
uh thing um
okay so this um curly parenthesis they
they start a focused mode it ends here
after exactly thousand conflicts right
then the stable mode here with the with
this bracket here ends here and this uh
difference here is measured in peaks not
in conflict right uh um now for this
instance could be that it's actually
almost the same but in general it's not
and here you for instance also see uh
that in
the the stable mode only did like a one
restart here from in this whole face uh
which is of course not
not much right
um all right so that's the um
[Music]
stable and and uh and focused mode
and um yep this uh splitting of the two
modes into stable
and focused together with having
actually an exponential resist
decision
heuristic for the stable mode which we
don't have in this satch solver yet
really gives very good results on
satisfiable instances and you get an
additional edge by doing these target
phases which i i will not explain um uh
in in this video
um so um this concludes the part on on
our um
on this mode switching and the restart
so we're going to talk about um
class database reduction next
so now let's have a look at um reduce
so uh once again it works in the same
way as this restart so we having a
trigger for when it's happening and i'll
talk about this uh
later even though like the trigger is
simple but like um the limit setting the
limit is is uh interesting so so i'll
talk about that uh and then we have here
this function uh which uh reduces the
cost database right and so what does
reduce mean well um you have these
learning clauses
and with every conflict you put in you
learn clause and they're kind of in the
range of um the length of these clauses
are sort of like um
yeah
40ish but
sometimes even way way longer like
hundred thousand even or ten thousand or
i'd like to have instances very
regularly every clause is ten thousand
and um you need to like propagate over
those clauses and we'll later see the um
at the end of this video i will talk
about sort of data structures for
watches which is important for getting
this fast but still right
assume you can do propagation fast you
still need to sort of like propagate
sort of somehow in the order of long
clauses right because otherwise you
would not need them
um and therefore um
these um
need to be removed in particular those
which are
um
[Music]
which are kind of useless and this this
term used
and useless is of course interesting
like how which which kind of heuristics
do you use for that in the old days it
was really like that so you could remove
maybe all clauses which are longer than
20. this was in the early set so
one rule and then the other rule would
be well um you put an activity uh this
was in minisite uh the the the rule so
you would
uh bump clauses actually um which is the
kind of level of use right so you're
bumping thing actually with a very low
alpha so like zero point like one to the
power
minus five like this low glue um alpha
we saw
and um
this already hints towards that sort of
um this bumping is not that important
maybe um the sort of the age then you
did learn the clauses is more important
in particular like um sort of um
uh maybe more recent clauses are more
useful right and and for that it's
unclear whether you really need the
bumping anyhow so
this was pretty difficult for a long
time to get right um
statist like likes the heuristics for
but then there was a paper by the
glucose glucose authors
who who talked about who figured out
that
okay i have an
apriori
metric which is the clue which we looked
at already which gives a very good
estimate at least like sort of for the
first
tier actually of
of clauses you want to keep
so what they showed experimentally is
the usefulness of a clause it kind of
goes down exponentially with the
with the clue
and
so you want to keep glue small clue
actually clue of two are always kept is
by default where a clue of two is more
it looks like a
like a ternary clause because rule of
two means um like a clue you can
interpret this is the number of
decisions you need to make this clause
propagating
okay so this is on the lower side so we
keep for sure all the clauses which have
um
at most uh
clue to and then what do we do with the
others
okay like first thing uh yeah you need
to protect the clauses which are reasons
you cannot uh
like uh
pull out the the reason from from a
literal which is on the trail this is
this thing um
then uh yeah um
in this implementation we combine
reduction also with removing
root level satisfied clauses and of
course you only need to trigger that if
there are new root level variables so
that's done here by this fix so if the
new fixed variables then you also mark
irreducing clauses as garbage
otherwise you only work on redundant
clauses for this clause reduction and
actually this over here separates the
redundant and error that closed in two
separate
stacks
and then this uh makes things a little
bit faster
but it's not completely true because uh
the most sort of the costly the hotspot
in this reduction is actually updating
the the watch list and
we found a way around this in in
keysight but i'm not talking about that
uh here and by sort of like splitting in
redundant and iriband and you do not get
rid of this hotspot of um
of uh um kind of flushing the watches uh
anyhow then uh this is the sort of main
heuristic we'll talk about this in a in
a minute so we're going to
gather uh candidates um right we don't
put on this candidate stake um this is a
stack of candidates here uh we don't put
on it like the clauses with glue one two
one zero or two uh then we sort these
guys um then we mark garbage candidates
like there's um
heuristic involved here which means like
like these are now sorted so some of
them are more
some less useful and then of course we
throw away these
less useful clauses and how many and in
the original papers they they've thrown
away half of them
um i throw away 75 for another reason
which i'm going to explain
next yeah and then as i said this is the
the hotspot because you kind of um you
now need to walk this occurrence list
and then access clauses randomly in
memory
and
and that's um
because you need to remove um from the
watch list these references to the
um to these clauses which are removed
like either satisfied or reduced
and then you can go through these uh
stacks irredundent clauses or redundant
clauses these two here uh which um
which uh
and and just really physically remove
remove the clauses uh and flash the
references in them okay
so that's it and then i will at the end
you're going to unprotect the the reason
clauses again
so now let's let's let's have a look at
at least three so first one
like gathering the candidates like i
already explained this a little bit then
sorting them yeah and haven't talked
about that and then uh you also um need
sort of a policy for which to keep so
let's first look at uh gather uh reduce
candidates classes that's it
so we go over the list of all redundant
clauses right and this is the style of
the stack of all relevant classes and
um right then we need to skip these
protected ones which are like reasons um
and then we might optionally want to um
like also check whether the class is
satisfied but only if their new root
level assigned variables since the last
time we did that
otherwise and this is um a really an uh
in
um
after like la la many years like the
local optimum i'm in there and there's a
paper by gurdeep and mate also had sat
um two years ago in in in this spawn
where they kind of throw machine and it
came almost to the same conclusion but i
i heard they have updates on that one so
i'm curious about that anyhow so what's
this
um
well um there's a boolean flag i have in
the so in each clause we saw this maybe
before and this boolean flash tells you
it has this clause being used in
conflict analysis right
uh so um um
here right so if you analyze the clause
uh during this um
we discussed this loop in extensively
before
so we went backward like all these
literals are false except for the
implied one which was marked recursively
reachable from the um conflict then we
called this clause also as useful
because it it contributed to to this
conflict right
and we had to resolve it away to get to
the first uip clause
um okay this is this flag and and we
we're uh getting the value of this flag
here this is this used but then
we reset it right so whenever we do a
full floss reduction we've reset
these used flags so that means we're
going to only sort of look at
was this clause used since the last time
this reduction
was running
okay and if it was well we don't put it
as a candidate so you kind of keep all
these clauses which were used since the
last time we did the reduction
yeah this is the thing i already
mentioned so we have this reduced link
which is constant and this is two so if
if the clue is smaller equal than two
we'll also not uh consider it a
candidate otherwise we'll consider the
clause as a candidate
okay so this is the the the gather um
gather
redundant one next one after we have
together we have to sort them and this
also has an interesting
heuristic
um it uses here this comparison function
so so actually when we later um
remove useless uh process we start at
the top of the stack
and pop from the top of the stack so so
to the right are those used more useless
clauses and the on to the left are
are um okay now we get these two clauses
so this is quick sort maybe you don't
know how how c works but c has a built
in quicksort
and and this has a little bit strange
like usage so you take the a function
which returns an integer and if it's
minus one then the left argument is
supposed to be smaller than the right
one so whenever i return here minus one
like for instance here
then uh yeah the first argument is
smaller than the second one and with the
explanation i just made it means that
the the um the the clause is considered
more important than the the other one so
here
a
smaller clue is considered better than
than a bigger clue and and these has a
higher chance to be
reduced like recycled and in the other
in the other direction if c is actually
larger then you swap the two then next
that's a classical
example we have the size and the size is
working the same way smaller size is
better than bigger size you want to keep
losses with a small size
actually uh you can just do that
okay
and you will get
not a bad silver
it's um
with this used and all the other things
actually slightly slower but uses less
memory well because you focus on
on uh on on these um
[Music]
um
sizes first actually um the very low
clue
like this uh keeping always like clue
two and also the used ones is more
important than variations of this scheme
at least this is my my experience with
experimental data and then here at the
end um yeah we're kind of the idea was
is is done in a sequential way uh like
it's like a 64-bit
index and this way you kind of take also
the h into console so um
older um clauses are one means like
less
useful right
okay and otherwise this makes it
kind of also deterministic with respect
to different implementations of of cuser
because it's
non-stable in in in general
by the way for the we use this q sort
also for for sorting these um stamps
right but there the stamps are unique
like all the elements on the
on the decision queue have unique stamps
and therefore their stableness is of
sorting is is not an issue
and then uh last but not least we have
here this uh mark uh garbage candy did
and and what you see here is very simple
so we just pop from the stack of
quantitative
candidates until we reach the target and
the target here is um is um
[Music]
computed with this
reduced fraction here and um as you'd
have
now
okay you reduce fraction here and um
this reduced fraction here is 0.75 if i
said so that means like um 75 percent um
of the causes are removed right because
will uh remain
okay but then uh what you really do here
is only setting the garbage bit flag
because they are now still need to flush
these
watches which is at least for reduction
a very like a hot spot
um okay
so this almost completes our part but
there's a very intri intriguing and
interesting
part left and this is when we reduce
okay
and it looks very simple okay
so we just have a limit
which is measured number of conflicts
and yeah if this is hit but then of
course the question is how is this
reduce conflicts limit
set
okay uh okay so by the way so you see
here before i explain that that how you
remember the last number of fixed
variables uh at this point um and so
the here's it set right so the reduce
interval is is
is a fixed um
uh limit is 300 starts with 300 after
300 you do the first reduction and then
in principle after another 300 but it's
actually increased with the number of
reductions like with the first reduction
it's like um
well it will be one and then
it's almost linearly increased and this
is what the original um
authors of glucose proposed so they
would have kind of
done this right just reductions
but what i figured out in keysight was
that maybe you want to actually have a
sublinear
[Music]
increase
of this interval between two reductions
between two minus signs in this
picture and um this reduces of course
this will throw away more clauses and
this speed up the silver
and um it turns out that this seems to
be a good compromise at least in
keysight it was here i don't have really
really complete experimental evidence
for that but um so you take the
number of reductions and you divided by
the logarithm of of reductions and and
this gives you a slightly sub linear
increase of this interval instead of the
interval but note that already the
linear one like the one i said right
this one here this was a big improvement
when the glucose paper in 2009 came out
and this break became only possible by
having a better a priori metric for um
which clauses to keep like in particular
the one which says yeah well keep all
the clauses which have
most the clue of
of two
okay
anyhow um so i would say um getting to
this point and really figuring out how
to do actually and schedule these
reductions with minor variations
was one of the big improvement in the
last 10 years together with this john
sick or idea of um
of getting the um
like
phase saving and sorry mode switching
and not mode switching um and on the
south silver side and um yeah maybe
these target phases which i will not
explain here and they're also not
implemented yet which i presented
with matthias at the post workshop last
last summer actually in 2020
and there's the video and also slides of
it online we're actually working on a
journal paper so this seems to be it's
hard to evaluate but it seems to be
giving you quite some edge also as the
competition results from
last year's show where not only
kisat was making a big jump but also to
other solvers which implemented similar
ideas but i won't describe
this in detail so next i'm going to talk
about some other very important aspects
of um
of the sat solving which is like data
structures for
watching clauses and
we'll talk about that
next
all right so now we're going back to the
blackboard for one important part of sat
solving which um
uh well at least gives you a factor of
two more in the range of three and four
and this is about like low level data
structure it's also very important to
think about that in order to to save
memory so the the sas over we discussed
so far
is actually not that good so it has like
a four to eight more times more
memory than um
the keysight and but that also applies
to other softwares like edical and
and also mini sat
so what i'm talking about something is
called watches and and this is like um a
really intriguing idea when i first saw
it i could not believe it
so i had to kind of
i saw the paper and for two days i tried
to disprove the others but they were
right
and so of course now it's natural to me
and now it's my task to explain this
to you so to you um
maybe some of you have seen this before
but well uh okay so once again remember
we had trail and we had values and this
implication profit presented by the
levels and by the
values so what what else do we have well
we have the clauses and i was a little
bit like sort of imprecise there so
let's
let's see so um the the
the first um
simplest way of of thinking about this
so um right so we have now um let's say
uh literal
like 17 and maybe here is like i'm using
now dynamics again not the
sort of the unsigned version
and then you have here um
a
container like which is a list of
clauses in which these variables occur
and and of course um
one way of doing that would be
and that's for instance something i did
like in my uh sets in my qbf so the tour
is well if you have yeah so here the 17
uh occurs and and and maybe there's some
other literals like minus two okay and
then uh well here's maybe the next
clause with a 17 maybe a binary clause
this time i guess you get the idea so
you need like
additional fields and maybe if you at
the end you put a zero here
okay and then of course like
these would come from somewhere else
right like from the um and maybe this
one also uh right
um
so this is like for full occurrence
lists and their places can follow
currencies means like you need to watch
all occurrences of literals in classes
and that's for certain um
[Music]
errors important like for um
like pre-processing and but i don't talk
about pre-processing today and um
and uh but it's really costly so let's
think about it so so this thing here uh
um is of course like uh
for buy rate
and but what about here
this this pointer okay
well this is usually on today's machine
eight byte and maybe um so i'm maybe i
should put this in a different colors
yeah actually you want to have doubly
linked lists like in our variable move
to font thing so this would be
another eight byte
okay so that means like for every
literal um you not only have kind of the
pay uh
load which is four byte but you have 16
bytes
which gives you effective five rate
uh that's pretty bad so so maybe um we
forget about this doubly linked list and
it's of course like also possible but
then you need to employ again some
garbage collection scheme uh and you're
still like a factor three so this is
three x-ray because you go from four to
12 before you go from four to six uh to
uh 20 right so like three x with this
five fixed then you would again think oh
is this really um
that bad okay so this is why why this
scheme here is is
rarely uh used but before i completely
forget about that let me um
show you a scheme which
in the uh old days um uh sorry oops in
the old days um was used and um
and um this is where the name conform
it only watches two literals okay
um
and this was the observation in the jeff
paper back then in 2001 i think where
they um figured okay you only need to
watch two clauses and they're like two
implementations for that one the one i'm
showing here
is kind of the um
uh the one which was originally done but
which
um
was not in lintow's version of the code
right and um therefore it got
sort of lost so i got a hold of
uh recently of some old version of this
code uh but it's hard to compile in
today's machine so i'm not don't know
whether i can still resurrect that code
but anyhow um i independently kind of
sorry this was of course wrong this last
arrow the same um in in
in pico side so what you see here is
kind of the picosart version
and the mgf version for muskewish jeff
not for lint house jeff
um all right so first you would need to
understand this um
watch literal to to appreciate it but
maybe it's a good point to explain this
here so um
what was the really inside most
important one of the most important
insight in that paper was um that
and there are some predecessors of
working for saddle actually that if you
have a long clause like think of this as
10k long right then um
um it's really expensive to have all
these
occurrences and and what actually the
what you propose i forgot to to you
don't have these fields here so you have
a constant um
[Music]
um size um
um
only the first two have this watch field
so this was imprecise for me but you can
have like a clause of length 2 000 and
then you only pay the price here
initially yeah this would be 16 byte per
clause right um
and
now why is this enough well they have
this invariant that um um you watch two
liters and loss and they're like um
like they have to be um
um um both
unassigned
this is the invariant
or
a
clause
contains um
satisfied literal
satisfied literal and there's like some
smaller catch here so you want to make
sure that um when you um
when you uh
backtrack
uh among this um and this one has to be
a level um of this literal is um is uh
smaller equal than uh watched a literal
level
okay so this if you if you um
uh maintain these two invariances
uh somehow during propagation then
you're
you make sure that you never follow
miss propagation in in more important
you never miss
um
a clause which is actually unsatisfied
but you didn't find it right so if
you're not careful you might watch
things
which are
you might stop watching the clause or
not propagating the clause which is
unsatisfiable and then
remember in our discussion we said like
as soon as the number of variables goes
unassigned variables goes to zero we
return and say that the the formula is
uh satisfiable if you're not careful
here you would actually
um
claim the format to be unsatisfiable
while sort of there's still this clause
which you cannot reach which is
you've kind of unsatisf
okay with these two um
in arguments and and then um fixing that
during propagation you're getting
like almost the state of the art
but this is like like around 2001 in
2006 or so
okay um
in the um mgf uh
like in the zhif which was kind of um
the published the first published source
code or at least like the source code
which became available which was last
least i saw i didn't see the mgf code
for a long time
it was slightly different so there at
the um
what did i have here maybe five no sorry
and what was
five right
um
this arrow here is actually wrong so um
we're not watching uh the the claws head
so it points to the wrong direction
actually uh we're precisely watching
this literally like it's a point right
the pointers and then maybe really hear
the the point or address of
uh when you go through three
and then because you're not um
uh really watching the clause you don't
know where the clause ends and then they
put here like sentence maybe zero so
that you know the clause end in the in
the clause beginning and you need like
uh additional sort of
bits here for those literals which are
watched right like this one will of
course not be watched
um yes you see this is pretty uh like a
cumbersome and you still need like um
um
sorry you don't need these guys of
course these uh um
these pointers anymore but you need
these additional bits and maybe you can
do stuff them into the rest of the
literal so you can get away with uh
with um eight eight four bytes per
literal in in the course
the sentinels of course like they are
cheap
so this was um
lindau chang's
version
okay um now we saw already picosat and
um uh
and m chaff um
there was one catch though in that one
which now i raised but i have to redo it
because you're only keeping here the um
the sort of the the first two connected
okay and the rest
of the literals like let's see there's
like maybe four uh they don't have any
link fields and now you see
a 17 could be here it could be the other
field and then you would need to say
okay so this flight
belongs to 17 while if there's like 13
here then this point that belongs to 13
is it still simply list so a single list
linked singly list
list and therefore you still need some
some
sort of a garbage collection maybe
anyhow
what if um this guy violates now the the
overwatch property right so it could be
that um
17 is actually assigned to zero
now um
what we do here is and and this is um
then later also done in other solvers we
remove the sig 17 and place it
in another because maybe uh this guy
here
is also uh
assigned to uh to zero here
and and this is remains zero but here
there was like maybe an in
a minus five which um was
actually unassigned
okay um so you would not need to do this
uh check if this guy is one this is like
this would not violate the the property
but it's tricky and um and and uh
yeah that's uh uh another story
so anyhow so we we
we
swapped these two guys right and
this has um the strange effect that the
claw status the glasses are not the
literals in the cluster are not like
immutable they kind of change during
propagation
um right and this is um again this is
mjf and
picosat
and
but um
this is not the best scheme so around
that time already um
people uh came up with the following
observation what if
yeah this is fine but what if here now
you have a clause which has only um two
literals like maybe
minus 19 and again 17
well then you have um again pointers
here
right
and um yes so these pointers of course
now can point to the the start of the
clause because we know that the the
pointer is for one of the two letters
you know from where you come right you
start propagating from the from the 17
here and the um um right and then you go
to this clause and then you see oh i
need to go here because the this is the
uh 17 then i see where which okay you
need to go this this pointer right
i guess you get the point um so you um
need to follow these things but here
it's pretty bad because you're um
you're wasting a lot of memory and in
particular because we discussed this
already there like a lots of uh
cash
over usage here
so for this binary clause we're having a
really
like
overhead and then of course as you
probably see one point to access one
point to excess uh one pointer excess
like for every clause you have an
additional
pointer um
access
and this is put and
yeah and the the chunks you need to get
in there are bigger so that is why um
already partially in z chef
but then later in mini sat
the following scheme became
state of the art
instead of
having here um
um
uh directly linked lists right
you would actually have a stack here so
the stack would contain usually a power
of two number of entries
and and this deck has uh uh well uh
begin and um
uh end and then sort of like these guys
are
invalid right um
uh and there then you really point
directly to the clause and there's like
no um yes so maybe 17
minus what did we have 13
and this guy was the other guy the
longer one which i of course don't
remember anymore with the what the uh
literal was right but you get the point
right
so um
the advantage here is that this thing
here you only need to load it once so
this gives you one cache miss
and
um
yeah this will be fast uh so no overhead
and you you shrink the size of this
claws
memory
okay but there's more you can do and
this goes back to um
stookie and true and this is called
a blocking literal and uh oops i should
have kept that one
okay um so
they observed that
or this us actually was observed in
other solvers and so as i remember also
writing about that is that um often the
other watched literal so this is the the
the other watched literal so you should
write it below
so
the other
watched
literal that when i traverse this clause
starting from
17 right then
this this minus 13 is the other watch
literal and that is in practice very
often
true actually so so i think like in my
picosaur paper i said 60 percent
but they're still true probably today so
so um
[Music]
at least this non-significant part of
this um
of these
if these
excesses are completely useless why is
it useless well i do this point of the
reference here right this one here
and and then i uh get this clause memory
here um into the cache and then i figure
out with 60 probability oh well i
shouldn't i don't need to to look at
that clause because the other literal is
actually true and moreover it's it's
often the other watch literal even in
long clauses like we had this
um sorry long claws here before which
um where the other watch literally was
maybe uh minus five or so
and also that one is included in this uh
in this uh
metric so one of course like needs to
redo this experiment
okay so um
so you you visit these clauses without
um
any um use
and that's bad so
instead
of doing that
um the um
the basic idea here is um to um to
increase the the size of this stack
which
which uh you anyhow have to um
um kind of
access at least one rates and extend it
to include
here a blocking literal
right so in this case um it would be
just let's say
minus 13.
for binary clause right
here for the uh lone clause uh we had
like a minus five right
um but and we'll see this later this is
not necessary it could be any claw any
literal actually could be here or seven
so it might be minus five but it could
also be um this seven here so i put the
seven here so it just has to be i'm not
the other watch it should just be
one of the the literals in the clause
and the reason we cannot really enforce
that it's the other watch is because
otherwise this would require during
propagation uh to update um
uh the the other
sort of the other watch
when we uh traverse the claw stay for 17
and then we need to we swap 17 for some
reason but then uh yeah 17 is not the
other watch or five anymore so we need
to go to the watch list of five and
update the watches there but it's not
necessary so we can here have uh five
and seven and now of course what we do
is actually
before we make this uh
dollar dollar dollar
memory diff d reference so this is like
a dollar i said
uh then um
we're um just checking here and this is
also just dollar
whether this certain is actually true or
what maybe the 7 rate
and if this is true
we know it was assigned before um
before 17 or at least at the same
decision level actually that's the
important part
and
therefore i can uh just
not visit that class completely um
uh
uh sort of uh
avoid this dollar dollar if for instance
uh
seven
and uh third minus 30 now goes through
all right so this is a blocking literal
and goes back to true and stupid
blocking literal
but there's more to it
but this mortal it was also invented
earlier actually where people said okay
so these binary clauses occur so often
actually
in the sub competition um last year
their instances with hundred millions of
of clauses and only 60 000 non-binary
clauses
okay and then it turns out if you really
look carefully at this that you don't
even
need here um
this
whole clause anymore because um also
like if there's like a 13 somewhere
right
then
would
also have here a stack
with 17 in it
and
a pointer to that clause right
so in in essence the clause is
completely represented by these two
entries in the
ending watch list
okay so that's why we can really remove
the whole clause
it's not as easy as you think because
you're um well in this analysis function
you saw before in in
in uh satch
there was just one loop which went over
one reason clause if you now have sort
of like two different kind of reasons
it's engineering-wise a little bit
tricky so there are like two types of
reasons binary clauses where you don't
really have the clause where you only
know okay it was derived by a binary
clause
and there are these long ones and um
yeah an distinguish so this makes the
code uh
more tricky
uh furthermore and um
now it becomes really sort of very
interesting in a claiming is that i
reached sort of the absolute limit i
thought like i had it be lingy link but
it's not true
so this guy here this minus sev the 13
right
occupies now if you think about and it's
actually also true for so this thing is
actually 16 byte whites in in
uh in search
and why uh because the set so we were
looking well because this thing here is
um is eight by pointers and you need to
keep things here aligned in the struct
and and then actually put here actually
also the size which is kind of redundant
but we put it there
and
okay um so why can't we just kind of
shrink the whole thing and just sort of
steal a bit from the literal field and
mark it as sort of um
binary
and and then only use like a four byte
for this guy
so a binary clause would then have four
four bytes here and uh
right this goes away four bytes here uh
of course now the problem is that your
uh the the the table here on top would
have this shape right
so because for the long claws you still
need a reference and uh it's clear we
cannot afford eight byte again because
then the whole thing becomes strange so
you would want to have here a four byte
index of that which then again limits
the number of clauses you can can access
but
then you really get to the the absolute
minimum so this is four byte this is
four pi this is four byte and then you
have this mixed so you have then a mixed
a watch stack list of uh binary like
four byte um small um
sort of watches uh and then for the
large clauses you have the blocking
literal uh plus a bit that this is a
large clause uh and um the the eight by
there's like an another
and that's why i put here like space for
another dot here another issue here
well uh there's one bit you need for the
whether it's binary or not
but then in addition right yeah but it's
unfair whether this clause is uh um
irredundent or not right okay so if you
um have um the clause in memory as we
also saw like in satch you could just
have a bit there for denoting this
clause is irredone and or is redundant i
mean for a garbage collection it's not
really like for reduction it's not
really an issue because you keep these
binary clauses anyhow
but um
for um like the elimination for
pre-possessing everything which really
need to know whether clause is redundant
or not
this is not feasible so you really need
to sort of put here
another bit here um into the um uh uh
this is for the binary uh
and this here is for
um
a redundant bit whether the
whether the um like this watch
corresponds to a redundant clause or not
even though the clause is actually not
there
but with this you can greatly reduce of
course the memory usage
of the sats over by um roughly factor
4 to 8
and this way really handle big instances
what do you gain well our current
machines get to the limit that you reach
with this scheme um so as i said like
a keysight can handle 200
million like two to the power like um 28
variables and after that it it just
gives up uh also like this offer by
offset of course is this restriction so
this gives you like 16 gigabyte if you
take eight byte aligned um
um
[Music]
it by the line uh um
clauses in an arena where you take the
offset and things like that so um
anyway so what i figured in practice is
like that with this scheme uh you're
getting um up to sort of
like instances which only run in 128
gigabyte but if you have machines with
26 56 gigabyte memory of 512 then
you might really sort of jump across
this sort of
barrier
and uh increase everything by effect of
two but then the bets thing is of course
that you suddenly need twice as much
memory right so as soon as you have a
machine which which
affords which which gets like keysight
to the limits
which is say 256 gigabyte of main memory
then another server which will not use
this um sort of compact scheme and like
just one or two bits more uh would
require already twice the
memory uh footprint and you would need
to buy a machine with
let's say a half a terabyte
okay um now um i would suggest we'll
we'll look at the the code and uh for
that i have um here um
pre-run um
search
which also shows off one feature here of
such such as this
possibility to completely
disable features like blocking clauses
so if you take the the optional block
then you're uh disabling that and you
get like for this um slightly
more harder factoring uh example we we
we already looked at before and then you
get it like a yeah
an estimate like how much you gain just
by these blocking literals and and and
as i said right it depends like how your
count rate if you start off with the
with the with the faster version then
going from here to here gives you a 50
percent slowdown while from here to here
is of course like uh only like 32 3
and but still is like a considerable and
if you add a couple of these things
together you can easily
make a bigger a bigger improvement
um
okay so maybe i show this non-blocking
for this no block first so you just need
to put this
environment um
sorry this preprocessor variable and
then you get that
but then um
if you search for this end block right
this is the slope down propagation and
there's some more so you can completely
remove restarts reduction uh you can
also combine them and actually maybe i
should show this too there's like a
combinatorical testing
script which of course
failed because i just changed something
but
in principle it would cause it would um
uh it would um
reset hard with two
oh there was uh an error i'm not sure
why why why this happened um
uh
okay and anyhow so we're going to um
this combinatorial testing should
should should in principle work so maybe
i didn't check it on this latest version
and
then this was the point um
uh all these options here uh even so you
can switch off learning completely this
is the worst thing for that i really had
to hack actually the
the script the the regression script to
disallow harder benchmarks because
without learning um everything would
break down um then um i didn't talk
about loss minimization
uh today in this video so um this needs
to wait and then the starting here this
would disable sorting off the bump
literals uh and so you see you can
switch off also this mode switching with
this table and focus and see like what
the what the software behaves but
there's no no blocking here and now uh
really um
shows you what this blocking idea is
about like
this is our reference to our clause
and then we'll add like these two more
things and and
in principle you only need like a bit
here which says the clause is uh binary
not but because um
we have like wasted this four bytes
anyhow right um
and we need like for the blocking
literal the full 32-bit uh unless we'll
be going down with number of variables
we can as well just to put the whole um
size there because these two guys would
have on a 64-bit machine each four bytes
so the whole thing like eight byte plus
this eight bytes again on a 64-bit
machine
as front pointer to the clause then
we'll have uh here the the stack
which
oh
what was that
uh this this deck uh which
for the
watches uh with the begin ending
allocated as usual and um
and then the actual watches here are um
just a big array like the like the
reasons here we looked at before and
also the uh the mark flex rate and um
yeah i didn't talk about say face saving
uh this is
also about these target phases which
also needs to go into a another
talk
all right uh so these watches are then
just like an area of stakes and each um
like um
each area has here um
um
the begin and the end so maybe go back
to the uh drawing that you see again so
so each of these guys would have um
like um
[Music]
begin pointer
and uh an end and an allocated pointer
and maybe i'll just do them in in red so
that you see what i mean so this guy
here has a
begin end pointer and
then of course an endpoint which points
to the sort of valid part and the
allocated is is
is here you need that for kind of
um
like linear um
accumulated reallocation
effort
okay um
that's uh very basic and then um
this is the code which
puts a watch into a literal and it's
actually only complicated because of
this if diff here which distinguishes
the cases where you have clocking
scrolls in which not right if you don't
have any blocking neutral and
nothing has to be done this is parameter
here with the blocking is useless uh
otherwise you put the size there of the
claws and the blocking literally
and now comes the sort of important part
watch the two first literals in the
clause right so you take just the two
first literals and you put them there
this also means there are really no
clauses which are
uh unit and there are no clauses which
are uh empty right so they're kind of
done by global flags the empty clause is
an inconsistent flag and the um the the
clause are just like global root
assignment
okay then you watch um like like
exchange wise of uh lit zero is the
uh pre literal for the
logarithmic flavor fluid one and lit one
is the one for literal zero
i i guess you get the point so this is
uh actually not the complicated part
about watches you just do this for all
clauses
the the real um
the real of course is meat of all this
is in in the propagate literal function
and but before i show that let me first
show you the uh the propagate
completely so the propagate
uh boolean called
constraint propagation this just gets to
the trail right and and then
has um
has here a pointer actually to the
literals which have already been
propagated and then all literals to the
right on the trail stack need to still
pre-propagate and that's what we're
doing here in this loop unless there is
a conflict okay and then we get from the
trail uh at this position is propagate
position we get the literal which needs
to be propagated and propagated
until we find the conflict
and the real complicated and one sort of
the the most important and uh hotspot
function here is this one
propagate literal and yeah i don't
have time to go over all indices but i
want to go briefly over it
because it has maybe some some
interesting aspects here you're not not
aware of so first of all
something which
also pioneered in keysight last year is
related to what i already said for this
mode switching you might to watch really
compute the time taken in this proper
gate right big propagates the hotspot
and because it's the hotspot you can
take the effort in that hot spot and use
it as a kind of virtual time to make
things
deterministic and in the simplest way to
do this is
computing memory excesses so that's also
what
donald knuth does in his books he
doesn't compute um sort of the running
time obviously he uses giga mems like
the number of billion uh memory
operations however i found this
slightly inaccurate
for for our um
users here because many memory accesses
in particular in the same cache line and
we're optimizing for that even
do not cost much so what you really want
to do is you want to measure these kind
of random non-cash
memory excesses
and um here is like what i found which
seems to be working seems to work
reasonably and the reason why i think it
works reasonably if i look at the
running the the amount of time spent in
blocked and switched um
um
search uh during the sorry focused and
stable search
if this mode switching is enabled which
is controlled by this ticks then you
really see that it's like almost 50 50
and of course it's not like completely
like maybe 40 or something
and
but it's very close and that's why um
this is pretty accurate i claim uh at
least like an effector of two um so um
we'll just take the this number of
watches and then you take the the
assumed watch like a cache line size
which is 128 on most machines at least
on this intel machine i'm showing this
you divide it by the size of the
of one watch right and that gives you
rough estimate for for the number of
cache lines you're going to to visit
when you when you propagate this
particular literal and um
this one here is this a single dollar
sign rate um i i mentioned before where
you need to go through the
you want to need to you need to get at
least access the the begin pointer of
the stack
all right and then comes the loop and
then you're kind of walking that
watch stack um
and by default we keep the watch um
damn thing i have not discussed before
but if you kind of propagate and you go
into a clause and you figure out oh i
found a replacement then of course that
literally you started the propagation
with is not watching the clause anymore
and then you need to replace it in this
case you need to drop the watch right
because otherwise you would watch this
clause multiple time more than two times
okay and then because this is default
which is keep it and now comes the um
blocking part so if you have blocking uh
then you just get
out of the watch the the blocking
literally you check its value and if
it's larger zero well you can just keep
the watch in it you don't need to
access the
the force no watermark this is a very
fast sort of path here in the solar
which is we saw gave sort of 50 speed um
then
the other part is then we can get the
size as i said like it would be enough
to say okay it's binary not because if
it's binary then we actually don't need
to go to the clause at all because the
we like in the binary clause the apple
watch literally is clearly the blocking
literal i mean i have to make sure that
it's true but
yeah
and then you only need to
look at the value and if it's the other
blocking the literal value is zero we
found the conflict and otherwise you
just assign it
assignment is actually um slightly
costly so so i i put here like one
dollar and um
okay now comes the very um expensive
part right and
if blocking is on
then um of course
this the size of the clause is now large
flaws non-binary otherwise it's uh it's
clause but this is the only difference
here between blocking
and non-blocking
so now we need to access the the clause
the first part is here where we um
access the literals and i don't have
time to explain that what's happening
here but but here uh we're really
accessing the first time the cache line
in which the the claw sits and most
likely this cache line is not in the
cache so because this sets over success
memory completely randomly and therefore
we pay a tick for that
okay now um
we get this other watch and because it
might be different from blocking literal
and also check its value if it's true
we'll also do nothing so we just um
remember that actually so we're updating
the blocking literal um with that one
because now that one is better because
it's like true
and and therefore
next time we would we do this we might
not need to go to pay this tick um
all right now um
yeah this is some normalization because
i want to discuss um but now we're
searching for the replacement so here's
the loop over the the literals of the
clause right and we start of course not
at the first literal but at the the
third one like literals plus two uh
because this is where we try to find the
replacement right we try to find like 17
swapped with
something else
okay and so we just walk this um
this uh this clause unless this clause
is really long but i don't really check
this in addition then this is really
just like already like captured by this
one tick
and
then um if the replacement value here is
is larger than zero we do the same trick
and as before we can just replace the
blocking literal and don't need to
actually do the swapping
this is pretty tricky and to convince
yourself that this is true actually that
you don't need to update this one
otherwise we're at the watch
otherwise
well it's um
it's uh it could be the replacement
value is
unassigned so that means we found the
literal which is unassigned and we put
it as a replacement
watch
so we dropped the previous watch that's
this one then swap the two and now i
have to watch it of course right so this
is swapping the literal which for which
we started the propagation and this is
like watching the replacement
okay otherwise um the replacement
is uh false the present value is false
so we walked from starting from three we
walk to the end of the clause
and all the literals are false
okay now um we check again the value
which was the other
watch as value
and if that one is um
is is actually assault like assigned
then it has to be zero because we
checked the true case already above uh
then we found the conflict and report
the conflict ring
and then
the third the very final
situation is that this other value is
now unassigned right because the the
true case was done above where we
replaced the blocking literal
and then here was the conflict and now
the last case is where we really assign
this uh the course to the
uh uh we designed this this uh literal
this other literal um like the watch
the other watch literal with the
um
with the clause and uh which has
traversed as reason
okay
uh well we
um because the q kind of follows the p
we need to keep also this this thing um
like
like in case of conflict where we have
an early airport uh still um consistent
okay um so um this um
is in a certain sense the i would claim
the most um
technical part in the current version of
this silver and uh but it's really sort
of needed it's like already on like a 15
year old technology not like a
brand new and
therefore i wanted to show you
this
in detail
so this brings us to the end of this
tutorial i hope you enjoyed it and uh
you will try some of the source code i
presented it's on guitar but just for
you to remember there's lots of other
material out there on start serving also
by me and so just gave a tutorial as i
said um at the sat smd summer school
there's a video also there's a cpir
master class all on my web page a lot of
tutorial slides from previous years from
summer school etc of course there's like
a sat solvers like at least a dozen sets
over some of them winning competitions
it's
my pleasure if you
would take some of these and work with
them and also in particular this last
one which i developed for this occasion
which i continue to develop for for some
more time uh which um we call satch
right for sad solo from scratch so have
a look play with it and i hope you will
have as much fun with uh sad solving as
i did in the past thank you very much
bye